>> From the Library of
Congress, in Washington, D.C.
>> Levon Avdoyan: I have the
pleasure of introducing someone
who did research in the African
and Middle Eastern Division.
I also have the pleasure
to introduce someone who,
if we were giving an award
for innovative titles,
would no doubt have
won it today.
To a Professor -- Assistant
Professor of History
at Skidmore is going to speak
to us about "Biceps and Balls,
Physical Culture in
Late Ottoman Bolis."
And for those who -- of you
who don't know what Bolis is,
Bolis -- Polis is the
Armenian word for Istanbul,
Constantinople, and it
brings me great pleasure
to introduce Murat Yildiz.
>> Yay.
[ Applause ]
>> Murat Yildiz: Levon,
you're too -- too kind.
So before I begin, I would like
to thank Levon and the Library
of Congress for organizing
this amazing conference
that really -- I think, we
can all attest to this --
that reveals the
breadth and richness
of Armenian history and culture.
It's an honor to be here.
My talk today, as Levon
mentioned, is entitled "Biceps
and Balls, Physical Culture
in Late Ottoman Bolis."
Okay, so in fall 2010, I
started to conduct research
for my dissertation
project in Istanbul.
I initially envisioned the
dissertation as a study
of the intersection of sports,
nation building, the body,
and gender during
the late empire
and early Turkish republic.
And more specifically,
what I wanted to do was,
I wanted to investigate the
ways in which the bodies
of young men served as a
central site of nation-building.
Like many Ottoman historians, I
started in the [foreign word],
or the Ottoman archive for
the Prime Minister's office,
which basically --
which serves as the --
as the primary repository
for state archival documents
in Turkey related to
the Ottoman Empire.
So my searches resulted
in me sifting
through government reports
on physical education,
and team sports in schools,
government programs,
and voluntary associations.
They offered a number
of insights
into the burgeoning interest
in sports throughout
Istanbul during the time.
However, they left
me dissatisfied.
They left me dissatisfied
for the following reason.
The documents created
the impression
that the Ottoman government was
the central actor in spreading,
institutionalizing, and
popularizing sports.
And in order to complicate
this narrative,
I sought to diversify
my sources,
and explore the representation
of sporting activities
and institutions in the
expanding public sphere.
And in order to do this,
I turned to the press.
Magazines and newspapers
written in Ottoman Turkish
from the period offered
a rich set of textual
and visual coverage,
and discursive framing
of team sports -- mainly
soccer, gymnastics,
competitions, and sports clubs.
The Ottoman government wasn't
absent in these conversations.
However, it was de-centered
from the narrative.
In other words, the Ottoman
government emerged as one
of many actors, albeit an
incredibly powerful one,
contributing to the spread
and popularization of sports
in the center of the empire.
And I found myself asking
what was the significance
of these different
representations of sports.
In order to answer
this question,
I decided to bring these sources
and archives into dialogue.
And I did so by reading
magazines in the morning,
and files from the Ottoman
state archives in the evening.
Now, this methodological
exercise revealed a number
of insights, one of which was
that some non-government
institutions were represented
in certain places
and not in others.
Specifically, I noticed
some clubs that emerged
in government reports
were absent --
were absent from
discussions in the press.
Now, for example, this report --
this report from the
Interior Ministry is a list
of voluntary associations,
written in Ottoman Turkish,
which included, but was not
restricted to sports clubs.
Now, I was familiar
with some of these clubs
from the sports press,
and others less so.
I was familiar with
some -- others less so.
So one of the clubs, which I
hadn't come across in the press,
was the -- and this is
the Ottoman spelling,
Artivasat Gymnastique
Gymnyeti [phonetic].
And I'll say something about
the spelling in a second.
This was the spelling
in Ottoman Turkish.
This is around -- a
couple from -- a couple --
maybe one, two, three,
four, five from the bottom.
Like all experienced researchers
-- and this is a joke --
I turned to the all-knowing
web for answers.
I appreciate that [laughter].
Did not figure into
my table of contents.
So these searches led me to
the work of Hayk Demoyan,
who was at that -- then,
and now, the director
of the Armenian Genocide
Museum in Yerevan.
Now, at the time, Demoyan had
recently organized an exhibition
at the museum, and
published a book
on Armenian sports
in the empire.
Now, these project reveal --
these projects reveal to me
that Artivast Gymanstique
Gymyeti [phonetic] had another
name, more than likely a more
commonly-used one during the
time, and that was Cruchesmeh
Marnamasagan Artivast
Ugumph [phonetic].
Now, why hadn't I encountered
this club in other places,
is the question that I ask?
Were there other clubs,
and more specifically,
were there other Armenian
clubs and figures excluded
from the documents that
I had been reading?
And if so, what was
the significance
of this seemingly-separate
sporting world
in late Ottoman Istanbul?
Now, I asked myself whether
early 20th Century sports
enthusiasts writing in Ottoman
Turkish knowingly excluded
Armenians from their
discussions.
In other words, were they
unaware of Artivasts [phonetic]
and other Armenian
sports clubs' activities,
or were they knowingly
ignoring them?
Now, an image of
three sportsmen seemed
to indirectly provide
the answer.
Now, this titillating image
featured three men posing
and flexing their
divine -- defined bodies.
That was a slip, but
it was actually very
enlightening [laughter].
Until that point, what had
captivated my attention
about this and similar
images was the presentation
of a gendered athlete
that was modern, strong,
beautiful, and also exotic.
The text, however, now offered
a whole new layer of meaning.
Now, at the top of the page,
the top right part of the page,
the text reads "our robust
bodies, [foreign word]."
Now, the three men
are [foreign word],
or the naval officer
[foreign word],
or the gymnastic instructor
of Galatasaray club,
and who was a major, [foreign
word], and the [foreign word].
Now, together, the text and
the images conveyed a number
of points to readers.
First, these were
robust, beautiful bodies.
Second, these Turkish male
bodies were cultivated
in sports clubs.
They're connected to --
these figures are
connected to institutions.
And third, these bodies
belonged to a group
of people, not just themselves.
Okay? So I asked, who were
claiming these bodies?
Was it the magazine?
Was it its readers, a broader
collective, a fan club?
Was there a difference between
these different communities --
communities of readers,
the magazine,
or a broader collective?
Now, I concluded that the
Ottoman Turkish sports magazine,
through this image and others,
was projecting an exclusive
reading of sports in Istanbul,
one in which Ottoman
Turks were the main,
if not the sole actors, okay?
And in doing so, what
the magazine was doing --
it was erasing the presence
of some Armenians --
excuse me, some Ottomans, and
foregrounding the presence
of others in the world
of sports in the city.
Now, this conclusion haunted
me, because of its implications.
Like the magazine, at that
time, I was contributing
to the historical erasure
of many Ottoman citizens --
more broadly, and more
specifically, Armenians.
Now, I asked, could I write
an alternative history
that accounted for, but did
not reproduce, this erasure?
And if so, what would
this history look like?
Was it different than the
project that I had set
out to study as a
graduate student?
So I concluded that
the answers were yes,
I could write an
alternative history.
However, in order to do so, I
needed to expand my analysis
of the historical actors,
spaces, and institutions
that made up physical
culture in late 19th
and early 20th Century
Constantinople.
What did this require?
This required an expansion of
the project's archives, sources,
as well as the languages
that I used.
And it was at this point that I
began to study western Armenian
with a tutor, a very kind,
generous, and lovely tutor,
and consult Ottoman Turkish,
but also Armenian sources.
Now, this proved to be
an immensely challenging,
but also rewarding exercise.
Now, the new methodological
approach offered exciting
insights into the ways in
which Ottomans, from a plethora
of different ethno-religious
communities,
shaped the defining
contours of sports
as a shared civic
culture in Istanbul.
As a result, this approach
fundamentally reconfigured the
scope of the dissertation.
And now, the metamorphosis of
the project enabled me to build
on the insights of a
new body of scholarship
that graduate students and
junior scholars of Armenian
and Ottoman studies
were producing
over the past decade, okay?
Now, bringing together sources
written in a diverse array
of languages, investigating
spaces, and transformations
across ethno-religious
divisions, and refusing
to treat communal boundaries
separating Armenians as Turks
as historically static
and impenetrable.
This new body of literature has
produced what historian Lerna
Ekmekcioglu refers to
as an entangled history
of the late Ottoman empire.
And in doing so,
this scholarship has made
significant contributions
to both fields, but also
helped challenge this --
basically, this divide
between --
a firm divide between
Ottoman and Armenian studies.
So what I'm going
to do now is --
and this is what I'm going to do
for the remainder
of the project.
I'm going to focus on the
ways in which sports can serve
as an under-studied lens through
which we can write an entangled
history of the period.
And specifically, I'm going
to examine the ideal
masculine characteristics
that Ottoman Turkish
and Armenian sports enthusiasts
worked out in a variety
of spaces in late
Ottoman Constantinople.
Now, Ottomans from a variety
of professional stripes
and interests contributed
to discussions
about the ideal man
and his antithesis.
Novelists, journalists,
intellectuals,
as well as modernists,
all offered views
on the defining characteristics
of this new type of man
in the capitol more
specifically,
but also other urban centers
of the Ottoman Empire,
and the broader region.
Now, a major contributor
to these discussions was the
physical culture enthusiast.
So during the late 19th
and early 20th Century --
centuries, advocates of physical
exercise and team sports argued
that it wasn't sufficient for
a modern, middle-class man
to study secular
subjects in school.
This in and of itself
was a debate.
But it wasn't enough to
just study secular subjects
in school, learn western
languages, work in an office,
frequent social functions,
and dress in dapper clothes.
He had to develop athletic
acumen, regularly exercise,
and maintain a healthy
and robust body.
Now, some of the earliest
contributors to discussions
about the importance of physical
exercise in the construction
of the ideal man were educators
in a variety of Ottoman schools.
It was during this period
that educators introduce
and gradually institutionalize
physical education
into the curriculum of a number
of different type of schools --
civil and military, foreign
missionary, and a diverse array
of non-Muslim communal
schools --
Armenian, Greek,
as well as Jewish.
Now, two leading institutions
were Mekhtibi Sultani
[phonetic], or the Imperial
School, and this is an image
of young men posing from
the Imperial School,
and Robert College.
Now, Robert College was
founded as an American college,
while Mekhtibi Sultani was
based on the French lysee model,
and was a government
institution.
Now, Turkish and
Armenian students
at both institutions
were exposed to the idea
that they needed to perform
physical activities in order
to develop strength and athletic
prowess, build character,
cultivate mental and
physical disciplines,
as well as acquire a
competitive toughness.
Educators asserted
that by exercising
and cultivating these
characteristics on campus,
students would develop
into physically, morally,
and spiritually sound young men.
According to supporters of
sports, the regular performance
of gymnastics in particular
offered multiple benefits.
One of the primary
ones was a strong,
defined, and healthy body.
There's no debate there.
Lifting weights, stretching,
and exercising helped
students develop a firm body,
and to fight off
different types of diseases.
And this is the type of
language that is used
in a variety of different
sources.
This hygienic, beautiful body
was envisioned as a modern one.
Okay, so what we're doing
here -- this stands --
may stand out as a
beautiful body now,
but what we're seeing is
the historical production
of that idea.
And it was deemed
to be a modern body
because its development required
work, discipline, and effort.
Now, while gymnastics were
deemed an important physical
activity at Mekhtibi Sultani and
many private minority schools,
school officials at
foreign institutions
such as Robert College
were more concerned
with encouraging team sports,
and forming school teams.
This is the Istanbul Dodgers.
That's a bad joke.
It's a baseball team
from Robert College.
Educators believed that team
sports, such as baseball,
soccer, and basketball,
even moreso than gymnastics,
helped students build trust in
each other, cultivate a respect
for rules, and develop a
commitment to teamwork.
Soccer and basketball's
popularity did not catch on --
excuse me, basketball
and baseball's popularity did
not catch on, while soccer,
on the other hand, did.
Okay. Now, another space that
advocated a distinction vision
of the relationship
between physical exercise
and masculinity was
the sports club.
So during this period
of the late 19th
and early 20th centuries,
clubs --
sports clubs mushroomed
in different neighborhoods
around Istanbul as spaces
where young men could exercise.
Now, upwardly mobile
Armenians and Turks,
as well as Istanbulites from
various different backgrounds --
ethno-religious backgrounds,
created and joined these clubs.
And this -- the emergence
of sports club is part
of a broader transformation,
and that transformation
was the creation
of voluntary associations.
Now, sports clubs
were predominantly,
although not exclusively,
spaces of male sociability.
And what they did was, they
represented crucial sites
where historically-novel male
subjectivities were formed,
negotiated, and performed.
Now, what these spaces did
was, they attracted young --
likeminded and like-bodied
young men
by offering them a private space
where they could spend their
leisure time training their
bodies, performing
sports, socializing,
and building homosocial bonds.
So what you're also seeing is
the creation of leisure time
as a space that needs
to be filled with moral,
productive activities, and the
sports clubs provided this.
So what sports clubs did was,
they served as a testing ground,
a testing ground of an emerging
middle-class masculinity
in Istanbul where new
conceptions of the self,
defined in relation to the
body, physical agility,
a distinct look, and one's
ethno-religious community came
into being.
Now, to a large extent,
these clubs embraced
a shared civic vision
of the defining characteristics
of middle-class masculinity.
Young men needed to regularly
exercise, compete on the pitch,
maintain a well-defined
physique, regularly bathe,
shave their cheeks, wear
neat and dapper attire,
attend social functions,
and also read.
This is a litany of different
things that they needed
to embody and to perform,
and the sports clubs
provided the space
in which they accomplished this.
So at this -- but the same time,
these clubs also projected
an exclusive ethno-religious
understanding of
masculinity and sports.
So sports clubs were
established along ethnic
and confessional lines,
and attracted members
from a specific ethno-religious
community.
And they served as spaces
where young men built
ethnic-based solidarity
around a popular
activity in the city.
Now, clubs conveyed
their shared civic
and exclusive ethno-religious
reading
of masculinity in
a number of ways.
So the main language and
symbols used, and the eponyms
that organizations adopted
projected a distinct
ethno-religious identity.
So some clubs explicitly adopted
names -- religious names,
excuse me, while others
were named after a heroic
or mythological figure of the
club's respective community.
So for example, the Maccabee
Jewish Gymnastic Society
[assumed spelling], the Hercules
Gymnastics Association [assumed
spelling], and the Armenian
Dork Club [assumed spelling].
Now, in doing so, club founders
sought to construct an awareness
of the idea that the club
served as a modern fraternity
of young men who were
inheritors of a deep history,
a history of their
community's corporeal strength,
robustness, and valor.
Now, club uniforms, which often
featured different scripts,
ethno-religious symbols, and/or
posters conveyed the idea
that this was an ethnically
and religiously exclusive
fraternity of young men.
So here we have the Besiktas
Ottoman Gymnastics Club.
We have Ottoman Turkish
being used, and actually,
in the back -- this is
a fascinating image --
there's a verse from the Quran
with a bulging bicep as well.
Obviously, you all have this
poster at your house [laughter].
And here's an image of
the Armenian Dork Club.
The -- for -- the title
doesn't carry the same resonance
that it does in Armenian,
and in English, obviously.
Those Armenian speakers,
you can appreciate that.
Now, a young Turkish and
Armenian man became a member
of an athletic club
by agreeing to abide
by the club's internal
regulations.
Here are internal regulations
of the Dork Armenian
Physical Training Union,
and the Galatasaray
Physical Training Club.
And paying regular
membership fees.
Now, after becoming a
member, what happened?
He received an identity card,
which featured his name,
and the date in which
he was registered.
So what you're seeing
is a cultivation of --
cultivation, production, and
the performance of a self here,
but also that's part of a
broader community, right?
Community of the Besiktas Club,
or the Armenian Dork
Club, right?
Now, what did membership
provide?
It enabled young men access
to the various amenities
that the clubs provided,
such as a gymnasium,
a full set of gymnastics
equipment,
and a shower, as well.
And this is some of the ways
in which clubs distinguished
themselves from others, right?
Who had the best shower?
Who had the best gym?
I hear people laughing,
but, you know,
this is serious stuff
[laughter].
How do you choose your gym?
Now, these were things
that, you know,
Bulsahais [assumed spelling]
and other community members
were grappling with at the time.
Now, membership also
enabled young men
to perform their
athletic dexterity
in newly constructed
spaces throughout Istanbul.
So basically, new, cool spaces
where people would gather,
such as stadiums,
gardens, and theaters.
Soccer matches -- more
properly, football matches,
but we're not talking
about the pigskin.
We're talking about the global
sport -- athletic competitions,
and gymnastics exhibitions
attracted large crowds
of spectators.
It facilitated both intra-
and inter-communal
social interactions,
and what it did was, it
celebrated the appearance
of young men wearing club
uniforms and performing novel
and physically challenging
activities.
Now, many of the
athletic events,
such as the Armenian
Olympics, or [foreign word],
Maccabee's annual
gymnastics tournament,
as well as other shows
and competitions,
were all organized
in the same space.
And this was the main space.
Oh, that's of the
Armenian Olympic games,
but that's in the
same venue as this.
This is the Union Club.
And a number of these activities
maintained striking similarities
as well.
So sports clubs,
therefore, served as spaces
in which young men cultivated
distinct notions of the self.
Now, central to this
identity was the commitment
to a distinct understanding
of the body.
Now, Turkish and Armenian
members deployed photography
as a means by which they
recorded their commitment
to a shared corporeal look.
Members had their photographs
taken while dressing
in dapper suits, starched shirts
and ties, but also as well
as posing bare-chested in
order to highlight their sense
of style and beautiful physique.
Now, there are two images
that I want to show you.
So these images --
and they're part
of a broader kind
of sportsmen genre.
The one on the right,
but also the left --
and I think of them as two
sides of the same coin,
that young men -- upwardly
mobile young men had taken
of themselves, and
also shared as tokens
of friendship, and
potentially more.
Now, these images provide
basically visual representations
of these two interconnected
tastes and looks
of the gentleman athlete,
which club members
celebrated and promoted.
The one on the left is Ali
Sami [assumed spelling],
of the predominantly,
although not exclusively,
Turkish Galatasaray
Physical Training Club.
And I should note, because
this is being recorded,
that I'm not a Galatasaray
fan, necessarily [laughter].
I appreciate that.
As well as Yetvart [assumed
spelling], on the right,
Shahonazar [assumed spelling]
of the exclusively Armenian
Artivas Physical Training Club,
okay?
Now, sports clubs served
as one of the main spaces
in which Istanbulites
contributed
to a broader discussion about
middle-class masculinity.
However, these were
not the only sites
in which young men experimented
with these novel ideas.
The press, for example,
was the more public --
was a more public space
than the actual association.
Now, the growth of
literacy and the mushrooming
of reading rooms throughout
Istanbul and other urban centers
of the empire ensured that a
wider array of the citizens --
excuse me, of the
empire's citizens.
Not just members of athletic
associations, were visually
and textually exposed
to the view
that young men should regularly
exercise, perform gymnastics,
and participate in team sports.
So to rephrase, I
mean, think about it.
You didn't have to be a
member of a club in order
to see men performing in
the stadium, the theater,
and the garden, but
also, you could read
about that in the press.
And these were becoming
increasingly common,
both in terms of the
publication of these ideas
in daily newspapers, but also
specialized magazines, okay?
And now, what these publications
did, or what they constituted,
at least in my estimation,
is a public forum
that provided Istanbul's
growing reading public
with articles focused on
particular sports, scouting,
and other sport-related
leisure activities,
but also on a wider array
of issues of health,
hygiene, and lifestyle.
And what these discussions
did was,
they offered this aspiring
middle class with instructions
and guides on how
to become young,
modern men by playing sports,
having fun, exercising,
and training their bodies.
Now, while the physical culture
press embraced shared masculine
ideals, like clubs, they
also conveyed exclusive
ethno-religious ties.
And this is accomplished
both through the languages
that are used, as well
as addressing its
reader, all right.
So the fact that
Turks are addressed
in an Ottoman Turkish
publication as the reader,
or Armenians, and specifically
Armenians from Constantinople,
suggests that the ideal reader
is from this community, right?
And so, what you're
having is the construction
of an ideal Armenian self,
or an ideal Turkish self
in these publications.
So written by educators, leading
members and administrators
of sports clubs, doctors, as
well as government officials,
these publications insisted on
the idea that young men needed
to regularly exercise.
And they needed to exercise
not just at the gym --
and this is what's fascinating
about it, that you can exercise
at the gym, in a
school, but also at home.
So what you're having is
the broadening of the spaces
in which you can
cultivate a new self.
Now, the sports press
regularly ran guides,
and here's an example
of a guide.
An illustration in
text and image
on the defining characteristics
of the ideal male body --
proportionality, strength,
and health were all
treated as interconnected.
A person who maintained
a proportionate
and defined body was
considered strong, healthy,
attentive, and disciplined.
Now, in addition to indicating
acumen and competency,
the proportionate, flexible,
and defined male body
was treated as beautiful.
And this is a really
interesting point,
how the term beautiful
is not -- it's --
we're seeing it being gendered,
but it's also applying
to men here.
And you see both
the Ottoman Turkish,
[foreign word] being used,
and [foreign word] being
used in Armenian, okay?
Journals soon created entire
sections for photographs
of semi-nude young men
run as regular features.
Here are two examples.
The portrait -- photographs
published
in these magazines
included captions,
and this is what's
interesting, right.
Without the captions,
these are just --
these are bodies that you can't
necessarily identify whom they
belong -- to whom they belong.
But because they're
collated with text,
what you're having
is the inscription
of confessional difference
on these bodies, okay?
So here is a body of Jervat Bey
[assumed spelling] on the left,
and Wailim Safhibay [assumed
spelling] on the right,
both identified as
Ottoman Turks.
This is an image of
Krikor Hagopian, and again,
you have the inscription on
that body as an Armenian body
with the Armenian text.
In addition to this, there's
a description of that body.
Here's -- and the
description is the following.
It refers to Levon
Hagopian [assumed spelling]
and his brother.
His brother's image doesn't
make an appearance next to his,
and the description
is the following.
"They are among the few
Armenian youth who take care
of their bodies and
glorify the Armenian name
through their bodies, will,
and muscle," end quote.
That's an intense sentence.
So together, what these
images are doing is,
they're establishing that
these bodies -- and again --
and I haven't really
talked about this yet,
but this is a global phenomenon
at the time, in the late 19th
and early 20th Century.
Levon is raising his hand.
He's agreeing with me.
No, he's not.
But these -- this image of Levon
Hagopian [assumed spelling] --
and Levon is a beautiful
Bolsahai [assumed spelling] man,
but that -- Levon can be found
in Paris, in New York, right,
in upstate New York -- hat's
where I currently live.
Saratoga Springs, Los Angeles --
but it can also be
found in Bolis.
And now, because that body
is identified in Istanbul
as a beautiful body in the
imperial capitol, it's global,
but it's also imperial.
With the text and the
publication of that body
in this publication,
it's also confessional.
So simultaneously, that
body is rendered global,
imperial, and confessional.
Now, while educators
in the sports press
treated physical exercise
as the primary means
to construct the
defining characteristics
of the ideal man, other
voices promised quicker
and less conventional ways.
Istanbul's multi-lingual
daily press is replete
with advertisements for pills,
which promised to provide men
with vigor and muscle.
So an early 20th Century
advertisement, for example,
addresses, quote, "those
who have lost the strength
of youth," end quote.
So these are pills that promise
to provide people
strength, okay?
Now, other products sought to
help men who were impotent.
Strong, beautiful, and
healthy men were supposed
to have a strong sex drive.
So -- I know it's a
shock to all of us here.
Here's an a-historical
statement that I'm making.
Impotence was a sign
of weakness, okay?
Now, Amrita [assumed spelling]
-- this is a publication --
excuse me, a type of -- an ad,
and a product, served as one
of the most well-known
products that promised
to restore the virility to
all impotent men of all ages
in the capitol who, quote,
"conduct a regular life,
but silently suffer from the
mistakes of their youth."
And we can hear dun, dun, dun.
Amrita ran identical
advertisements
in Ottoman Turkish,
Armenian, Greek,
and French daily newspapers in
order to reach these poor souls
in the -- in the capitol, who
were all afflicted by these --
who were all afflicted
by impotency.
And here's the --
here are the ads.
Now, these two advertisements
publish an identical caricature
of an dapperly dressed gentleman
and the following headline.
"Only for men, an important
announcement for those
who have lost the
strength of the body."
Now, the advertisement is --
you know it opens a really
interesting question about,
you know, marketing.
I don't know how successful
they were, because there's a lot
of text here, but the
text is very rich,
in terms of what it
-- it goes on to talk
about how people actually
become impotent, what are some
of the immoral activities
that they engage in.
Alcohol is one of them.
Gambling is one of them,
and, I should warn you,
dark and thick tea -- and tea
as well, according to Amrita.
So if you have had a lot of tea
and coffee today, you may want
to look into Amrita [laughter].
Okay? According to the product.
Now, it goes on.
It says, "I have prepared a
miraculous and effective pill
that will give hope
and joy to those
who are afflicted by impotency.
This pill that I have
invented will heal the health
of those men who have
been completely weakened
because of bad practices, or
have been under the infrequence
of unfavorable circumstances."
Keeps that kind of broad.
"This cure that I have invented
is a blessing for everyone.
It gives everyone
health and strength."
Now, what's going on here?
At first glance, gymnastics
guides and advertisements
for pills and tonics published
in Istanbul's multi-lingual
press seem
to be fundamentally different.
However, I would argue they
maintain striking similarities.
They all -- they're
all concerned
with helping men
rejuvenate their bodies.
And as a result, they
provide an insightful window
into the diverging approaches
that educators, writers,
manufacturers, and
advertisers proposed
that the ideal man adopt
in order to be a strong,
beautiful, and virile body.
Now, moreover, these conflicting
approaches constituted an
emerging market, which treated
the body as a central site
of male subject formation.
Now, in conclusion, the writings
of educators about sports,
physical culture, the
activities of club members --
they all demonstrate that
young men articulated
and performed their
gendered identity
by cultivating a defined body
and regularly exercising,
and were reading about exercise
in late Ottoman Istanbul.
Together, sports, sports clubs,
and the press served as spaces
where Istanbulites from
a variety of backgrounds,
including Armenian and
Turkish, experimented
with new conceptions
of the self.
Now, while I have demonstrated
that Ottomans espouse similar
views about the importance
of physical exercise,
techniques of the body,
and athletic acumen, I have also
attempted to highlight the fact
that Ottomans worked out
these ideas within spaces
that projected exclusive
ethno-religious ties,
and that were firmly divided
along confessional lines.
Thus, these clubs and the press
might've embraced the share
masculine ideal, but they
also cultivated an exclusive
ethno-religious identity among
their readers and members.
Now, this, I want to stress,
should not be interpreted
as contradictory, at
least in my estimation.
On the contrary, I think
it invites us to examine --
and I'm speaking
to all historians
of the time period, really.
It invites us to examine
the ways in which Turks
and Armenians experimented with
and shaped the defining contours
of other novel practices,
beliefs,
and norms within the boundaries
of ethno-religious
communal spaces
in a late imperial session.
Thank you for your attention.
[ Applause ]
>> Levon Avdoyan:
Thank you, Dr. Yildiz.
Our next speaker is a dear
friend of mine, and a colleague
of many, many years, Theo van
Lint, who is the professor
of Armenian studies
at Oxford University.
He has chosen one of my favorite
poets of the 20th Century --
as a matter of fact, one of my
favorite Armenian poets ever.
His talk is on "Poetry,
Patria, and Pedigree,
Eghishe Charents' Monuments
and the Muse's Discontent."
>> Theo marten van
Lint: Thank you, Levon,
for organizing this
wonderful gathering.
I am sorely tempted to
do 10 pushups before I --
[laughter] before
I start [laughter].
From the poetry of
the body to the poetry
of the Muse's Discontent,
so -- [laughter].
Thank you very much.
Yes, so you see, friendship
blossoms in many ways,
and leads to all
kinds of things.
"Poetry, Patria, and Pedigree,
Eghishe Charents' Monument,
and the Muse's Discontent."
A poem rarely exists
entirely on its own,
revealed by divine inspiration
without any cultural context.
Almost every aspect of it
exists thanks to a network
of conventions, applied
and tweaked anew
in a never-ending flow
of creative activity.
These carefully-chosen
conventions carry particular
meaning, and their application
by poets through space
and time is potentially
very powerful,
as they place their
work both in a tradition
and in their own
contemporary context.
My contribution today
addresses this double phenomenon
of conventionality and
contextualization through a poem
by the Armenian modernist
poet, Eghishe Charents.
It was the poem that
triggered these considerations,
not the phenomena addressed.
For me, the source of the study
of literature is the text,
from which all else follows.
In January 1934, Charents
finished a poem called
"Monument" in Armenian,
which is a first indication
that something particular
is going on.
So "Monument" -- the poet could
have called it [foreign word],
the usual and indigenous
Armenian word.
Why use a word that had clear
western and ancient overtones?
In fact, it hails
back to a famous poem
by the Latin poet Horace
that is [foreign word],
written just over
2000 years ago.
Its opening line
is [foreign word],
"I erected a monument
more durable than bronze."
The connotation with classical
imperial commemoration is
visually present as
well, as you can see.
The date is in Roman letters, in
literally monumental capitals.
They are not Armenian
ones, which are used
to indicate numbers as well,
as you know, or Arabic numbers,
as is common in the western
world, and as it was also
in the Soviet Union, where
Charents wrote his poem.
Yet, the reference
is not direct.
It does not bridge 2000
years without intermediary,
because the opening words of
Horace's poem, [foreign word],
are the motto of a famous
Russian poem Eghishe Charents
knew very well.
It was written in -- a
Century earlier, in 1836,
by Russia's national poet,
Alexander Sergeyevich Pushkin.
This is its opening line.
[foreign word], "I erected
a monument for myself,
not made by human hands."
What's going on here?
I'd like to spend the time
allotted to this talk trying
to suggest some answers
to this question.
First, let us look at the poems.
That's always the most fun.
Latin, Russian, and Armenian --
I began with the Armenian one.
So here it is, "Monument."
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
Twelfth of January, 1934.
In English -- whoops, this
is the young Charents,
more or less, returned from the
fighting around Van in 1915.
This is Charents as he may have
looked when he wrote the poem.
And this is the English
translation.
"I erected a monument for
myself in a difficult age --
" in a fraught age, perhaps --
"when everything was
going to ruin around me,
that for many years, for
centuries, had stood,
and had seemed immortal
in the world.
I wove my monument out of
songs profound and complex,
from thoughts that are red
hot anew, that carry life
in themselves, that can
flow in gushing forth
from the fiery heart of my age.
I was born in Kars.
However, in my soul, the song
of Iran was always a flame,
like an old native yearning
unquenched, but the native land
of my soul became
the entire world."
This is an image of the Church
of the 12 Apostles in Kars,
with the elevated
castle in the background.
You can just about see it.
Now we go back 2000 years.
This is a newspaper photograph
of Horace declaiming his poem
in front of his audience.
I will read this in Latin
in a very approximate
meter, I must say.
It's not simple to follow this.
So I will make mistakes.
Let it be recorded.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
And this is another 19th Century
impression of Horace, you see,
wearing the laurels
of the poet king.
The English translation here,
which will give us some more
insight, is by Ted Loker,
taken from the all-present
internet.
"I have created a monument
more lasting than bronze,
and higher than the royal
site of the pyramids,
which neither harsh rains nor
the wild north wind can erode,
nor the countless
succession of years,
and the flight of the seasons.
I will not entirely
die, and a large part
of me will avoid the grave.
Constantly renewed, I will grow
in the eyes of posterity so long
as the Pontifex and the solemn
Vestal visit the Capitoline.
Where the River Aufidus
roars, and where Daunus
in the dry summers,
ruled his rural folk, I,
risen to greatness from humble
beginnings, will be renowned
as the first to adapt
the Aeolian verses
to Italian meters.
Take the well-deserved
pride, Melpomene,
and freely grant me the wreath
of Apollo for my crown."
Personal fame and prowess
as poets are central
to Horace's poem.
Horace is one of the
most-quoted classical authors
in western civilization.
The Dutch big dictionary has
250 quotations from his work
that phonated into
21st-Century Dutch.
The reason for his fame,
however, does not lie
in the fact that
he was the first
to put Greek verse
into Latin meter.
That is of less importance
to us than it was to him.
To trace the itinerary
of Horace's work
of almost two millennia
is not my intention here,
nor can I trace the particular
root the Horace reception took
in Russia.
But through 18th Century ground
tours and enlightenment context,
including the strong
presence of French literature,
as well as their
school curriculum,
well-educated youngsters
like Alexander Pushkin --
or Sasha Pushkin, as he
would've been then --
would have gained
knowledge of the classics.
And here is Pushkin.
And he is again, without Getty.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
And [inaudible].
"I've raised myself a monument
not made by human hands.
The path of the people to
it will never grow over.
Its insubordinate
hat has risen higher
than the Alexandrian pillar.
No, I shall not fully die.
The soul in my faithful
lyre shall survive my dust,
and shall escape putrefaction,
and I shall be famous wherever
in the sub-lunar world
even a single poet lives.
Tidings of me will go out over
all great Rus -- " Russia --
"and every tribe in every
tongue will name me,
the proud descendant
of the Slavs, the Finn,
the Tungus who is now savage,
and the steppe-loving Kalmyk.
And for long shall I
remain loved by the people,
for awakening noble
feelings with my lyre,
because in my cruel age, I have
celebrated freedom and called
for pity to the fallen.
Oh, muse, be obedient
to the command of God.
Do not be fearful of abuse.
Do not demand a crown.
Accept both praise and
slander with indifference,
and don't dispute with fools."
This is Pushkin, what
he may have looked
like in 1836, by Pyotr Sokolov.
The translation of this
poem is by Catriona Kelly,
professor of Russian at Oxford,
who makes it a central pillar
of her admirable, very
short introduction
to Russian literature.
One may wonder, what binds these
particular three poems together,
so wide apart in time and space?
The interrelationship between
poems mentioned at the opening
of this presentation
and the trivial fact
of temporal sequence
give partial answers.
Charents built from Pushkin,
who built from Horace,
while Charents was, himself,
part of the Russian-language
reception of Horace.
Charents, the communist Armenian
poet, was raised on the Russian
and western European culture,
apart from the Armenian one.
The Latin poetic tradition does
not have a strong reception
in Armenian literature, quite
in distinction to the Greek one,
which is overwhelmingly
present from the beginning
of the Armenian written
tradition in the fifth Century.
It was only from the early
modern period onwards,
through the highly successful
and culturally savvy Armenian
merchants, as we have seen,
and the Catholic
Armenian Methodist fathers
that [inaudible] and post
[inaudible] European classical
reception entered
Armenian literature.
In the poems, a set of
binary oppositions seem
to present themselves -- poet
and patron, poetry and politics,
native region and the wider
world, and the direction
from local to
world-encompassing.
And two more construed
ones, perhaps,
fame versus civilization,
and the combination of poetry
with freedom over against
empire and oppression.
The latter opposition makes
itself more clearly heard
in Pushkin and Charents
than in Horace.
The life and work of all
three poets was defined,
to some extent, by a
patron, with all the shades
that word can muster, Maecenas.
This literally was the name
of the protector-become-friend
of the down and out Horace,
who was superbly gifted
but financially broke after he
had sided with the Republicans
in the Civil War
following the murder
of Caesar -- Julius Caesar.
Horace had received the best
possible education in Rome,
and then in Athens among
the elite of the empire.
Horace was then introduced by
Virgil, the other great poet,
to Maecenas, who
gave him a villa,
and thus the leisure
to write quietly.
I would like that [laughter].
Ere long, Augustus, the
emperor, offered him a position
as his personal secretary,
which he refused.
He also kept intrusions into his
independence by Maecenas at bay.
This is a paradigmatic example
of the way artistic independence
is maintained in the need
of patronage, and how
recognition can be an even
greater threat to it.
Being Augustus' personal
secretary would've left him
neither the leisure to
write, nor, one must assume,
the freedom to choose
his own themes.
I mean, this is 2000 years ago.
It's still very actual.
Directly comparable are the
cases of Pushkin and Charents.
The latter was embraced
by the socialist system
with state and art patronage.
Pushkin was a small
aristocrat of mixed heritage.
He also received the
best possible education,
the elite lysee of [inaudible],
followed by a life dedicated
to poetry and court
cavorting, or carousal.
However, Pushkin's outspokenness
soon earned him exile.
Then, his poetic career took
a turn, evoking Horace's fate.
Following the Decembrist
uprising of 1825,
Pushkin was interrogated
by the Tsar in person.
The poet came out
with honor intact,
but had to accept the favor
of the emperor's
personal censorship.
In practice, this
meant subjection
to Count Alexander Benckendorff,
founder of the secret police,
precursor of the KGB,
to the an institution
that might lend him another
term of exile, or worse.
We find echoes of this in
one line in Pushkin's poem.
You may wonder which one.
[foreign word], "in my cruel
age, I have celebrated freedom."
This line recurs, in fact,
in the opening line
of Charents' poem.
Nothing here about the
quality of the monument,
as in Horace's more durable than
bronze, and Pushkin's not made
by human hands, which by the
way is a reference to ikons,
that are not made
by human hands.
But "I erected a monument for
myself in a difficult age,"
followed by the devastating,
dystopian lines allowing
for an interpretation
denouncing the revolution he had
so enthusiastically
embraced two decades earlier,
as well as mourning
the genocide of 1915.
"When everything was
going to ruin around me
that for many years, for
centuries, had stood,
and that seemed immortal in the
world" -- the end of tradition,
the end of immortality.
Does Charents predict his
own immortality instead?
The last minutes allotted
to me, I would like to spend
on Charents' trajectory --
in particular, a brief
consideration of the state
of the art of poetry, and by
extension, but flowing from it,
the value of the word
in today's society.
Where we stand, there seems
ample reason for caution,
seeing the value of the
word in politics here
in the United States,
in the United Kingdom,
and in my native Europe.
Where it is difficult
to find people capable
to unite the remnants of
humanistic culture based
on the Greek Judeo-Christian
tradition into a vision
for the continent in danger
of caving in once again
to ignorant populism
and rampant nationalism.
Here, the muse's discontent
comes to the fore in full force,
as it had in Pushkin's
and Charents' poems.
For we must be aware of the fact
that both our disenchantments
of Horace's triumphant
proclamation of a victory
of poetry over politics,
and more generally,
of culture over politics --
after all, he had erected
a monument more durable
than bronze, the stuff
emperor's statues are made of.
He might just as well have
mentioned the word marmer --
marble.
Moreover, if Pushkin's laconic
final advice to the muse,
and to himself, [foreign word],
"and don't' dispute with fools,"
betrays a trust in rational
persuasion, in Charents,
we find a completely
different emphasis,
one that in my view
is now more actual
than it has been for some time.
[foreign word], "the native land
of my soul became
the entire world."
This is both a return
to Goethe's ideal
of [foreign word],
world literature,
and one to socialist -- to
the socialist international,
if you want -- an overcoming of
nationalism and limiting origins
in a forward-looking movement
towards a better world.
Much could be said about this,
as it represents a typical
Charentsian paradox,
in particular in
his later years.
The communists denouncing
totalitarianism,
and the cosmopolitan atheists
returning to the religious great
of his native Armenian
tradition, [foreign word],
even more appreciated by him.
Possibly an understandable
preference,
given the free poet's
temperament,
but this is not the time
and place to go into that.
What does need to be noted
is the seemingly veering away
from poetics to psychology.
Charents gives pride
of place to the soul.
In fact, what happens here is,
on the one hand, a consequence
of the socialist realist forging
of new souls, interpreted,
one is tempted to say, without
the encumbrance of ideology.
Of that, Charents had, by now,
become more than a little wary,
of which the opening stanza
of the poem eloquently
bears witness.
On the other, it is a
consequence of the power
of the alternative to the
ideology of nationalism,
the dire consequences of
which he had witnessed
in a genocidal attempt by the
Ottoman Turkish government
at the annihilation
of his people
under cover of World War I.
Precisely how the whole
world became the native land
of his soul is intriguing,
because that is
through the poetry, through
the power of the word.
Therefore, no veering away, in
fact, from poetry after all,
but the strengthening
of the bond
between poetry and personality.
The last years of Charents
life, in particular,
bear eloquent witness to this.
He set out on a journey
of absorption
and creative expression while
his life was in constant peril.
His work was taken away
from him, as were his wife
and children, and soon, his
health and freedom as well,
followed by death in prison.
The pressure must
have been unbearable.
On 28th March, 1937, he writes,
in quiet recognition of the fact
that he turned 40, and had
been a poet for 25 years,
"I am celebrating my double
jubilee, alone, and persecuted,
a poet exiled in
his own fatherland."
The late Charents awaits
deeper exploration,
and offers both pearls
and cups of bitterness.
The philological situation
of his later work is very,
very difficult, due to the
fact that it had to be buried
in the ground, and
we don't have anyone
to tell us how he
would have liked
to have eventually edited it.
And so we have various
editions of his work
that bear no relationship to one
another, nor a real account --
accountability of how
these are represented.
There is a parallel
with the work
of Osit Mumbo Schtum
[assumed spelling].
However, Osit Mumbo Schtum's
widow knew everything by heart,
and knew what he had
wanted to do with it.
So there was a big
difference there as well.
In 1937, Charents was somber
about what he proclaimed
in his monument.
It had been -- despite the
clearly disillusioned tone,
at least been partially
triumphant.
So he says, and there are
five separate lines published
together, in one case with
the fifth one lacking --
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
-- "you were born null
and void, like a number
with a zero overlooked.
In Kars, you may have been born,
but the world was
your fatherland.
Kars, and Maku [assumed
spelling], and the world --
which was your land, poet?
Kars, and Maku, and the world --
all of it was your land, poet.
Woe to you, Charents,
either way.
Neither your song nailed
it, nor your life."
Charents' restlessness
in his final years
does not seem directed
at the realization
of a political ideal.
It has become clear that the
communist experiment is both a
farce and drenched in blood.
The poet's remaining energy is
directed at two areas of life,
it seems, and this
needs checking --
poetry, and the exploration
of religions, always engaged
for the good of humanity.
What the conclusion has to
be about the relationship
between poetry and politics
is unclear so far, for me.
A political system
that murdered poets
by the dozens clearly took the
poet word extremely seriously,
feared it, and tried to kill
poet and destroy poetry itself.
Poetry is a means to find truth,
to insist on honesty in life
and society, forms part of the
wider endeavor to speak truth
to power, beginning with
oneself -- truth to oneself.
Dire experience stripped
Charents of all pretense,
and in the end, what
remained was the word,
the word that had also been
there in the beginning.
A contemporary of Charents,
W.H. Auden, in January 1939,
commemorating the death
of William Butler Yeats,
wrote three poems, in the second
of which the following
movement occurs.
"Poetry makes nothing happen.
It survives in the valley of
its making, flows on south
from ranches of isolation
and the busy griefs,
raw towns that we
believe and die in.
It survives, a way of
happening, a mouth."
Auden finishes the third and
final poem as a blind song,
in assured way keeping intact a
belief of the power of the word
as life-creating, and
as a life-giving gift.
You probably know it.
It's a fantastic poem.
"Follow, poet.
Follow right to the
bottom of the night.
With your own constraining
voice,
still persuade us to rejoice.
With the farming of a verse,
make a vineyard of the curse.
Sing of human unsuccess
in a rapture of distress.
In the deserts of the heart,
let the healing fountain start.
In the prison of his days, teach
the free man how to praise."
Such was the monument erected.
Did Charents seek to fathom
similar deep wellsprings?
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Levon Avdoyan:
Thank you, Theo.
Please do not break your leg.
Yes. We should've had
stairs on this side, too.
Again, my thanks for that
wonderful talk on Charents,
and now we go from friend to
friend and scholar to scholar.
And a denizen of Washington,
D.C., and the director
of analytical support and
production staff in the Bureau
of Intelligence and Research
of the Department of State,
Robert Krikorian, who will
speak on the "Re-appropriation
of the Past, History
and Politics
in Soviet Armenia, 1988-1991."
>> Robert Krikorian:
Thank you very much.
As a government employee,
I have to start
with my standard disclaimer
that my views do not
reflect those views
of the U.S. government,
and that will probably come
as no surprise [laughter].
Let me first really give
a most sincere thank-you
to my dear friend,
Levon Avdoyan.
Levon has been a friend and
a mentor for 32 years now,
having met in 1986 when I first
made it down to Washington,
D.C. So I have learned
a tremendous amount,
both from him personally and
from all the wonderful programs
that he has put on
through the Library
of Congress, so thank you.
Thank you, Mary Jane.
What I would like to do
today is tell a few stories,
and some of the stories
that I will tell,
some of you have lived through.
And some of you have
helped me with my research,
like my dear friend,
Nerses Hayrapetyan.
So what I am going to do is to
look at the role of history,
how history is remembered,
and the role that played
in undermining communist
legitimacy in Soviet Armenia
from the years 1988 to 1991.
This is part of a much larger
project that I undertook,
but what I would
like to do for today
for a few minutes is
extract the parts that relate
to how the first Republic
of Armenia was remembered
in Soviet Armenia.
Because this is being
the 100th anniversary
of the Independent
Republic of Armenia,
I thought it might
be a good pairing.
In terms of context,
let me just say
that I had the extraordinary
good fortune of living
in Soviet Armenia
from 1988 to 1991,
during the last three
years of soviet rule.
I got to Soviet Armenia
through a program
that the soviet government
had organized
for all ethnic Armenians abroad
to get an education
in Soviet Armenia.
Now, I did not need
a soviet education.
I had an American education that
I was perfectly satisfied with,
but I did not speak Armenian.
So I went to learn Armenian,
and it so happened to coincide
with the -- really
the renaissance
of the Armenian nation.
And so, for three
years, I got to witness.
I got to participate.
I got to observe, and I
got to gather lots and lots
of material along the way
that I was never quite sure
what I was going to do with.
But I knew that what I was
witnessing was important,
and so when I went back to
graduate school later in life
to write a doctoral
dissertation, I used a lot
of that material to try to
make sense of what had happened
in Armenia in those
three very short,
but very, very intense years.
Right? We have a sweep
of Armenian history
that goes back millennia, but in
that very short period of time
from 1988 to 1991, the
whole world changed.
Not just Armenia, but
the whole world changed.
No one predicted the
collapse of the Soviet Union,
except for someone
named Andrei Amalrik,
who wrote a book Will
the Soviet Union Last
Until 1980 -- Survive
Until 1984 .
Unfortunately, he
died before that,
before the Soviet
Union fell in 1991,
so he didn't even get
a chance to see that.
What I would like to do is
talk a little bit about --
again, to contextualize
about historical narratives,
and the role that they play.
They're really the --
kind of the cornerstones
of anyone's identity, right?
We have narratives in
the United States, right?
The words we use matter.
They connote either
where we stand socially,
economically, or politically.
Interestingly, in the Soviet
Union, history was one
of the first things that the
soviet state appropriated.
Imagine 1917 to the -- you know,
when the revolution broke out,
and then the following years of
civil war, foreign intervention.
The soviet state -- the
Bolshevik party was fighting
for its very survival.
Yet, it devoted very limit --
its very limited resources --
it devoted a considerable amount
of resources to making sure
that it controlled
the historical record.
It created something
called [foreign word],
a party committee
devoted to history,
and devoted to making sure
that the narrative supported the
ideological goals of the state.
So what that means is
that, in the Armenian case,
Armenia inherited the soviet
system, the soviet ethos,
if you will, but they never
accepted it wholeheartedly.
And there was always a
little pushback, right?
There was always
a little tension
between what the soviet
central authorities wanted,
and what the Armenian Soviet
Socialist Republic actually did.
So I think there
are two quotes --
and we don't have the
makeup artist here to try
to dampen the moisture, but
hopefully that won't come
out too badly on film.
There's two quotes that
I would like to use.
In the Soviet Union,
every profession had a
professional journal.
If you were a tractor driver in
Ufa, you had your own journal.
If you were a tube
player in Krasnoyarsk,
you had your own journal.
Well, the historians had their
own journals, too, right,
and one of them was called
[foreign word], "Problems
or Questions of History."
And every issue started with an
editorial, right, and that kind
of laid out what the party
line would be for that issue,
and kind of where
soviet history stood.
So there's a wonderful quote
from 1960, and it says,
"The study of history has
never been a mere curiosity,
a withdrawal into the past
for the sake of the past.
Historical science --
" and everything for
them was a science, so --
"historical science
has been, and remains,
an arena of sharp
ideological conflict."
Now, perhaps more indicative
of this approach would be
from Nikita Khrushchev, who
had a reputation, let's say,
for being somewhat more
earthy in his pronouncements,
and he declared that "Historians
are dangerous people.
They are capable of
upsetting everything.
They must be directed."
So that is the backdrop for
what I will now present,
and I have my clock here.
Tell me, what time would
you like me to stop?
It is 2:26.
Okay. So, the reassessment
of history at the end
of soviet rule in Armenia -- it
didn't take place in isolation.
It occurred simultaneously
with and as an integral part
of unprecedented
political, economic, social,
and intellectual changes
that were taking place,
a result of Gorbachev's
policies of Glasnost.
Developments in any one of these
spheres -- political, economic,
social, intellectual --
influenced the nature and pace
of change in the others in
an interconnected process
that culminated in the collapse
of soviet power in Armenia,
and the reestablishment
of an independent state.
These processes, in turn, were
deeply influenced by events
in other parts of the Soviet
Union and eastern European.
Mikhail Gorbachev's policy
of Glasnost gave
the initial impetus
to a more open discussion
of the problems facing
soviet Armenian society.
These early discussions,
which focused on topics
of contemporary relevance,
such as the environment,
the state of education
in the republic,
the status of the Armenian
language, Armenian culture,
also included an important
historical component,
as Armenians strove to
understand the origins
of the problems affecting
their society.
The search for the roots of
environmental, educational,
and cultural questions
in Armenia inevitably
involved the study of history.
For example, environmental
degradation was traced back
to the industrialization
policies of Stalin,
which led to a closer look
at Stalin's other policies
in Armenia, including the
drawing of borders and the loss
of Karabakh and Nakhchevan
to Azerbaijan.
The exploration of these
issues soon gave way
to a more broadly-based
reevaluation of the soviet
and pre-soviet Armenian
historical experience.
The emphasis on historical
issues was of more
than just academic interest.
It had political
implications as well.
Historical interpretation in
Armenia was given relevance
in February of 1988 with
the spontaneous formation
of a mass social movement
throughout Armenia agitating
for the secession
of the Nagorno-Karabakh
autonomous district
from Azerbaijan, and its
unification with Armenia.
The borders of Nagorno-Karabakh
were established
in the early 1920s with the
direct participation of Stalin,
who arranged for the
region to be placed
under the administration
of soviet Azerbaijan.
It was this perceived
historical injustice
that mobilized the Armenians
into action, with the hope
that under Glasnost,
a rectification
of borders might be possible.
Using history as a means
to demonstrate the justice
of their cause, Armenians began
to draw wider historical lessons
from their experiences
in the pre-soviet
and early soviet periods, which
steadily led to the undermining
of soviet legitimacy in Armenia.
In order to increase
their chances
of resolving the Karabakh
issue to their satisfaction,
Armenians turned to
history to demonstrate
that the region was historically
Armenian, and should be placed
under the control of Yerevan.
They pointed to the involvement
of Stalin and the injustice
that had occurred under soviet
Azerbaijani administration
throughout the years.
This instrumental use of
history by the Armenians
in 1988 was just the beginning
of a full-fledged historical
reassessment of Armenia's past,
the outcome of which would
have profound implications
for the entire nation.
The process of historical
reassessment was fundamentally
altered by the February-March
pogrom against Armenians
in the Azerbaijani
industrial city of Sumqayit.
That event, more than any
other, changed the course
of events in soviet Armenia.
It broke a tacit social contract
between the soviet state
and the Armenian people,
which had been in place
since the early days
of soviet rule.
This social contract
assured Armenian acquiescence
to soviet rule in exchange
for the physical security
and protection from the Turks,
Armenia's most serious
security threat.
Although this might not
seem like much of a bargain,
it must be viewed in the context
of the atrocities perpetrated
against Armenians in the
Ottoman Empire in 1915.
Despite the atrocities committed
under Lenin and Stalin,
they never reached the
same level of intensity.
This geopolitical reality
allowed Armenians to come
to terms with soviet
rule in their country.
The memory of 1915 was kept
alive throughout the years
of soviet rule by
survivors, by scholars,
and by the intense feelings
of the general public.
The persistent denial
by successive Turkish
governments only served
to deepen the importance
Armenians attached
to their national tragedy.
The events at Sumqayit had a
profound impact on Armenians,
and resurrected painful
historical memories and images.
The close ethnic and linguistic
ties between Azerbaijanis
and Turks only served to
reinforce the connection
between the two events in
the minds of most Armenians.
Sumqayit occurred so
close to the beginning
of the democratic movement in
Armenia that it is impossible
for this event not to
indelibly mark the course
of the movement from the outset.
Thus, from the very beginning,
the struggle over Karabakh,
and the creation of a national
democratic movement in Armenia,
perception of current
events was colored
by an understanding of the past.
And conversely, a
particular reading
of the past influenced the ways
in which the present
was seen and understood.
History and politics,
inextricably linked in Armenia
in the years leading up to the
dissolution of the Soviet Union,
and the interconnection between
the two played a leading role
in the determination
to secede from the USSR
and reestablish an
independent state.
The interpreters of the Armenian
past were not just historians,
but intellectuals
more generally.
And their deconstruction
of the soviet narrative,
so laboriously fabricated over
70 years of communist control,
would prove decisive
in the process
of redefining Armenian
national identity,
and laying the groundwork for a
post-soviet Armenian identity.
Through the use of the mass
media and publishing houses,
Armenian historians and other
intellectuals reshaped popular
perception of the past, which
in turn influenced the present.
The reassessment of history
in Armenia was neither
completely elite-driven,
nor did it emanate
exclusively from below.
Instead, it was a symbiotic
process, in which historians
and other intellectuals
commenced
with a wide-ranging debate
about the past at the same time
that the general reading
public was getting excited
about the fresh interpretations
made possible by Glasnost.
Popular interest in the past
meshed with a renewed interest
and renewed spirit
of scholarly inquiry,
as historians began
the dismantling
of soviet revisionism.
This resulted in nothing
less than a revolution
in thinking among soviet
Armenians about themselves,
and their place in the world.
Having become accustomed over
the years to be skeptical
of the heavy-handed
soviet approach to history,
the Armenian reading public
greeted Glasnost warmly,
and showed great interest
in the new interpretation
of their past.
Armenian skepticism,
in part, was a result
of the clumsy nature
of soviet revisionism.
It was also the result of the
extensive use of oral history
in Armenia as the elder
generations passed
down to the younger
generation memories
of a pre-soviet and
non-soviet past.
Discussion of the independent
1918 to 1920 pre-soviet Republic
of Armenia was closely connected
to and occurred simultaneously
with reinterpretation of events
such as the liberation movement,
the Armenian Genocide,
et cetera.
This was understandable, as
many of the leading figures
of the liberation movement went
on to play leading roles during
the independent republic.
And of course, the foundation
of the republic occurred
in the midst of war
and revolution.
Armenia became a soviet
republic in December 1920,
as a result of a joint
soviet-Turkish assault.
The new Bolshevik rulers
inherited a devastated
and exhausted country,
and needed to quickly
establish their legitimacy
and consolidate their rule.
One method of legitimizing
their rule was
to employ a tactic perfected
throughout all the lands
of the former Russian Empire.
This was to discredit
and delegitimize the rule
of the predecessor regime --
in this case, the Armenian
Revolutionary Federation.
As Marxists, the new soviet
leaders found the ideology
of the Armenian nationalists
anathema, and they lost no time
in leading the -- in labeling
the dashnaks as, quote unquote,
"bourgeois nationalists,
imperialist lackeys,
narrow-minded chauvinists, and
irresponsible adventurers."
They blamed the dashnaks for
the loss of independence,
and credited the Bolsheviks
with, quote unquote,
"saving Armenians
from the destruction
at the hands of the Turks."
By thus discrediting
the previous regime,
the soviets were able to gloss
over the uncomfortable fact
that they had allied with the
Turks who were responsible
for massacring Armenians,
and then jointly invaded
and occupied an independent
state.
The Bolshevik alliance
with the nationalist forces
of Mustafa Kemal was
completely ignored
in soviet historiography, while
the alleged voluntary reunion
of Armenia and Russia
was stressed instead.
The soviets portrayed
the leaders
of the independent republic
as inexperience bourgeois
nationalists
who understood nothing about
governance, and who were blinded
to the reality of Armenia's
dire situation by the promises
of the western capitalist
powers.
They accused Armenia of being
an outpost of imperialism
that was used to weaken
and undermine the socialist
revolution in Russia,
and drive an artificial wedge
between the working classes
of Armenia and Russia.
It's probably important to note
that Armenia really didn't have
a working class at this point,
but we don't have to digress too
far to see the contradictions.
The lack of information
and supression of knowledge
in Armenia regarding the
independent republic served
soviet interests
in several ways.
First, it allowed the soviets
to present the republic
as an experiment that failed
because of the inexperience
and immaturity of its
leaders, and their inability
to prevent the hostile
takeover by Turkey.
According to the soviet
version of events,
the adventurous dashnaks
had initiated a war
against the Turks, which ended
with the defeat of
Armenian forces.
Only the timely humanitarian
intervention
of the Bolsheviks prevented
the complete destruction
of the Armenian people.
This version also served the
interests of the communist party
in Armenia by portraying the
Armenian Soviet Socialist
Republic as the culmination of
Armenian national aspirations,
thus increasing their
own legitimacy.
This recounting of
the events of 1918
and 1920 was an important part
of the soviet grand narrative
for Armenia, which was
reinforced over the years
through constant and sustained
propaganda, both in the schools
and in the public sphere.
The information that
was publicly available
about the Independent Republic
of Armenia was almost
uniformly negative,
stressing the nationalist
and thus evil character
of the fledgling state.
Dashnak became synonymous
with bourgeoisie nationalist,
and the ultimate
political pejorative,
as were the terms
Musafatist [assumed spelling]
in Azerbaijan, Bazmachi [assumed
spelling] in central Asia,
Menshevik [assumed spelling]
in Georgia, and Banderite
or Pepurst [assumed
spelling] in Ukraine.
During Glasnost, however,
this soviet narrative came
under sustained criticism in
Armenia by both intellectuals
and the public, as a vigorous
and open debate developed
on the nature and significance
of the independent republic.
This was the first
independent Armenian state
that had been created
since the fall
of the Mediterranean
Kingdom of Cilicia in 1375.
The previous lessons transmitted
to the population by Moscow
through soviet Armenian
historiography were challenged
by new interpretations.
These interpretations stress
the important symbolic value
of the republic as an
independent Armenian state.
This debate on the independent
republic opened slowly at first,
as historians and the
public were hesitant
to openly discuss the
subject of independence.
There seems to have been
fear among certain circles
of intellectuals and the
public that discussion
of the independent republic
would be seen by Moscow
as a sign of disloyalty
and possible separatism.
Armenians were already being
accused of these things
because of their support for
Karabakh, and did not want
to exacerbate tensions further.
The only consistent calls
for independence came
from the Armenian
Self-Determination Union,
and the supporters of the
dissident Paruyr Hayrikyan.
At a public rally
on May 28th, 1988,
which was the 70th
anniversary of the declaration
of Armenian independence, a
telegram was supposedly sent
to the Supreme Soviet,
asking for that date
to be declared Armenian
Independence Day.
This group had not
yet been able to win
over the mass public support
for the idea of independence,
though, and throughout
most of '88,
the subject of the
independent republic was not
on the public agenda.
But as the conflict over
Karabakh intensified,
and an acceptable political
resolution seemed far-off,
attitudes began to change.
This change of opinion about
independence was escalated
in the aftermath of the
December '88 earthquake,
and the soviet Armenians --
excuse me, the soviet
authorities proved incapable
of alleviating the
suffering of the people.
Disillusionment with the
authorities was heightened
by the active participation and
organizational skill of members
of the Armenian Democratic
Movement.
Thus, from '89 on, more emphasis
on the independent
republic became discernible
in the public sphere.
This was most noticeable at
the regular mass meetings
that were held in Yerevan,
as symbols of the old
republic began to appear.
The red, blue, and
orange tricolor
of the independent
republic was in evidence.
It was considered a great honor
to be the chosen flag-bearer
by the organizers of
the mass meetings.
Some of my young friends at the
time made sure they got there
as early as they could, and
got to know the organizers
so that they would have an
opportunity to hold the flags.
And they would be willing to
hold them for hours and hours
in the blazing sun, and
they thought that that,
for them, was a great honor.
Buttons, pins, and other
paraphernalia related
to the Independent Republic
of Armenia were also produced
in large numbers by activists,
and distributed at the rallies,
or sold along the route.
Public curiosity about this
previously forbidden aspect
of the Armenian past was
mirrored by an increase
in scholarly interest.
One of the more prominent
historians of this new approach,
who's representative, but
by no means exclusive,
was Goodrik Sardariyan [assumed
spelling], who wrote extensively
in the mass media
on the formation
and development of the republic.
He developed the idea
that Armenia's most pressing
problems were the result
of its lack of statehood, also
noting that Armenians needed
to be more realistic in their
approach to political life,
and understand that having
a just cause was not enough
to ensure victory.
Sardariyan turned to the history
of the Republic of Armenia
in an effort to understand
the problems and experiences
of an independent state.
He criticized those embraced the
idea of an independent Armenia
without understanding
the full implications
of such independence.
Although he supported
the idea of independence,
he feared the consequences
of precipitous action.
He concluded that without a
sober assessment of history
and Armenia's current situation,
Armenians would end
the 20th Century
in the same way that
they started it.
This stark warning for caution
was echoed in other quarters
as well, but in the atmosphere
of escalating violence
against Armenia and Karabakh,
most people concluded
that independence would
be a better option
than continued membership
in the Soviet Union.
In recognition of the
symbolic importance ascribed
to the Republic of Armenia by
soviet Armenian intellectuals,
the Academy of Sciences
elected Richard Hovannisian,
the foremost scholar of
the independent republic,
to be a member of the
Armenian Academy in 1990.
This was one of the
very few times
that a foreign member was
inducted into the academy,
and was the first time
that a foreign historian
of the modern period
was allowed in.
This was a clear signal
that Hovannisian's work
on the Independent Republic
of Armenia was considered
indispensible for a fuller
and more accurate understanding
of modern Armenian history.
There was much talk among
historians for the need
to have Hovannisian's work
translated into Armenian as soon
as possible in order
to prepare the country
for renewed independence,
renewed statehood.
The new positive image of
the Independent Republic
of Armenia presented
Armenian historians --
presented by Armenian historians
was enthusiastically adopted
by local nationalists and used
as a symbol of local autonomy
and sovereignty in their
struggle against Moscow.
Thus, discussion
of the independent republic
carried an anti-soviet
connotation from the outset.
This was mirrored by many local
Armenian political activists,
who identified themselves as
dashnaks, although very few
of them actually knew what the
ARF's political position was,
or the party's platform, or
the party's goals beyond a free
and independent Armenia.
They were nevertheless
calling themselves dashnaks,
because to them, that
was the symbol for a free
and independent Armenia.
In the highly charged
political atmosphere of Armenia,
for most people, that
meant anti-soviet,
and being anti-soviet,
in some quarters,
became increasingly equated
with being pro-Armenian.
In this new spirit of defiance,
there was a reassessment
of the foundational
battles of May 1918,
the battles of Sardarabad,
Bash Abaran and Karakilisa,
in which Armenians were
able to stop Turkish forces
from invading the
eastern part of Armenia,
and finishing the job that
they had started in 1915.
Soviet historiography had
tended to portray these battles
as important instances
of self-defense
which saved the Eastern
Armenians from the same fate.
They were not viewed, however,
in the context of the founding
of an independent state.
Given that Armenian independence
was declared immediately
after these battles, it
seemed an odd omission,
but one completely in keeping
with the ideological
needs of Communist Party.
As Soviet legitimacy was
called into question,
these battles took on
an added significance.
In addition to their importance
as self-defense battles,
they were also presented
by historians and accepted
by the public as foundational
events in the process
of restoring Armenian
independence.
They ascribed new significance
to all this as the conflict
of [foreign word]
continued to worsen.
In Moscow, increasingly -- was
increasingly seen in Armenia
as unwilling or unable to be an
honest broker between Armenians
and Azerbaijanis,
the reestablishment
of an Armenian state was
discussed more frequently.
It was in the context of
current events that the legacy
of the republic came
to be viewed.
Part of this reassessment
consisted of trying
to draw lessons as to the
root causes of failure.
In conclusion, the historians
identified three main causes
for the failure of the
Republic to survive.
The first cause was
directly related to 1915
with the destruction of Ottoman
Armenians still occurring
at the time of the foundation of
the Republic and the territory
of the fledgling state flooded
with refugees, the establishment
of independent state was viewed
as an astonishing
feat in and of itself.
The second major
factor in the defeat
of the independent republic
was the attitude and behavior
of Lenin and the Bolshevik
Party, including Stalin.
Bolshevik collusion
with Kamala's Turkey
and the dismemberment
of Armenia only served
to delegitimize Soviet
rule even further.
And the third factor, identified
by Armenian historians,
was the indifference
and contradictions
among the great powers.
The promises to end
Ottoman oppression extended
to the Armenians during the war
led many Armenians to believe
that their hour of
liberation was at hand.
These promises went unfulfilled,
however, as the interests
of the great powers
took precedence
over any moral obligation
they have --
may have felt for the
plight of the Armenians.
So at the end of the Soviet
period Armenians were faced
with a choice.
And for most, independence was
not the first choice, right?
The choice was to try
to renovate the Soviet
Union to make it work.
But the way events evolved,
the Armenians had to rethink.
And so by -- in rethinking
their position,
they looked to history,
not just to the Republic.
They also looked to the
ancient and medieval period
where they were able to show the
continuity of Armenian statehood
from pre-Christian
era to the present.
They looked at the
Liberation Movement.
They looked at our
cultural inheritance,
our connections with the West.
And all of those things together
helped delegitimize Soviet rule
in Armenia and laid the
foundations for independence.
And, hopefully, that will
be a nice segue to my friend
and colleague, Nerses.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Levon Avdoyan: In 1994 I
met a young librarian here
in the United States.
And that was my first exposure
to the new library
world in Armenia.
I want to say a few words about
librarians in Armenia if I may.
As far as I'm concerned they
have been in the forefront
since independence of building
a new Armenia, and actually
in the forefront of
diplomatic efforts with all --
between the three states of the
caucuses, and I have nothing
but high praise for
the libraries
and librarians that I have seen.
Now, when I first visited
in 1996 after independence,
the conditions were
not very good.
There was no heat, there's
obviously no air conditioning,
the - so please don't
complain anymore [laughter].
The salaries were
nonexistent or very low.
These people went to work
under conditions that most
of my colleagues would probably
have resigned years ago.
And so all this to say that
I have nothing but respect
for all librarians
and especially
for the two librarians
with us today.
I call both of them friends.
And Nerses is not only a
friend; he's a [foreign word],
he's a brother of mine.
And I would like to introduce
to you one of the founders
of the Armenian Library
Association,
former Assistant Director of
the National Library of Armenia,
the Director of the Informa --
an Information Resource Center
at the United States
Embassy in [foreign word],
who has been actually, as a side
duty, regulating the exchanges
of Armenian libraries with
the Library of Congress,
and a specialist on book
arts and history in Armenia.
And Nerses Hayrapetyan will be
speaking about [foreign word]
and the emergence of the
contemporary Armenian press.
Nerses.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you, Levon.
It's an honor to be at
the Library of Congress.
Exactly 24 years ago I first --
my step was, first
step to the Library
of Congress was in
April 30, '94.
And I shall start --
before starting my
official presentation,
I should like repeat
the same sentence
like my friend Robert
told that my disclaimer
that my opinion not
necessarily, you know,
is the same like
the U.S. government.
So -- but I'm talking -- my
topic is rather interesting.
I was dealing with the Armenian
new periodical press or --
during those [inaudible]
movement years,
and little by little
collecting information.
Mostly bibliographic
information at that time.
If I knew that it is so
important to collect pieces also
because at firstly there is
not any library in Armenia
that has this all, you
know, rich collection of --
some [inaudible] data
now traditional press.
What is the -- ah, we have it.
Okay. Some is that originated
from the dissident
movement in Russia.
The Russian [foreign words]
coined the version of the term
in 1952 when he typed
copies of his poems
and included the not
some [inaudible] is that.
"Myself, by Myself"
publishes on the front page.
The individuals reproduced
censored
and underground publications
by hand or printed
on semi-professional printing
presses and passed the documents
from reader to reader.
Russian dissident
and prominent figure,
Vladimir Bukovsky
summarized it as follows.
"Some is that.
I write it myself, editi it
myself, censori it myself,
publishi it myself,
distribute it myself [laughter],
and may get imprisoned
for it" [laughter].
The history of Armenian
[inaudible] is
that started I should
say in '60s.
And in the Russians,
some is that rose
as an underground
movement to create
and distribute literary texts.
The Armenian sum is that,
was the political protest
for a national unity
and independence.
The roots of Armenian
[inaudible] is
that are closely tied
with the 1965 year
[inaudible] demonstrations.
On April 24, 1965, 100,000
protestors held a 24-hour
demonstration in [foreign
word] on the 50th anniversary
of the commencement of
the Armenian Genocide.
Around that movement, the first
legal political partisan groups
were established.
The National United Party was
founded in 1966 on April 24
by Haykaz Khachatryan, Stepan
Zatikyan and Shahen Harutyunyan.
The Party issued and
distributed the first issue
of its periodical Paros,
Lighthouse in October, 1967.
In 1968, they published
and distributed another
journal titled [foreign words],
in the name of the homeland.
And, lastly, in 1969, National
United Party published its third
journal, [foreign word].
When the founders were
imprisoned in 1968,
Paruyr Hayrikyan became
head of the party.
After the arrest
of active members,
the National United
Party, until the late '80s,
until the perestroika and
glasnost period, only one issue
of the Armenian [inaudible] is
their publication was published.
In 1981, [foreign words]
published the last, fourth issue
of Paros Newspaper .
The Armenian [inaudible]
that was reborn in 1987
when the Union for National
Self-Determination Party was
established by Paruyr Hayrikyan.
UNSD published the Independence
Weekly Newspaper ,
starting from October
24 of 1987.
The Independence Weekly was
the first alternative political
periodical not only in
Armenia but one of the firsts
in the entire Soviet Union.
The Independence had
chosen [foreign words]
or Armenian people,
your only salvation is
in your collective power
lying as your epigram.
And you can see it on the
first -- on the left side.
The self-published
was of small scale.
Only 85 [inaudible].
In the beginning, Independence
looked very simple.
Only text without
any illustrations.
In the state of being
a self-publishing,
the front page would often
feature the national emblem
of the Republic of Armenia.
Later, also the NSDU emblem.
The final pages presented the
sponsors of the newspaper --
of course, with their
permission.
Not only Independence did so,
but also other self-published
newspapers
as that [inaudible] et cetera.
It is worth nothing that
the newspapers were printed
by the personal means
of the publishers
and with the support
of individuals.
The materials were in a row
without any illustrations,
typewritten.
The plot was rich though.
The newspaper's priority
was the self-determination
of the Armenian Nation.
The idea of independence
of Armenia
and those were constantly
vacant consciousness
in the civil society.
The materials related to
this topic were very many
in the self-published.
[Inaudible] we and our
fight article appeared
in the very first number of
the newspaper where he spoke
of the necessity of
national self-determination,
mentioning that some people
are suffering from [inaudible].
He wrote that there are
no ever-lasting enemies
in [inaudible] lives.
Yesterday's enemy may
become tomorrow's ally.
He highlighted the idea of
national self-determination,
the nation's imperative to
control its own destiny,
and considered any intervention
on [inaudible] illegal
and non-human.
Offering to create
[inaudible] National Armenia
through a referendum,
the author thinks
that this very idea can
bring the nation together.
The Independence was one
of those few periodicals
that was keeping a chronological
record of the events connected
with our [inaudible]
moment in 1988.
The Soviet Union official press
was either silent on the event
or was presenting them distorted
in the light favorable
for the authorities.
The official press was
presenting the leaders
of the [inaudible] growing
movement as national extremists,
while the criminal
persecution against them
as fight against crime.
It is obvious that there
was a political presentation
against the leaders and
activists of the movement.
In the history of the newest
Armenian periodical press,
the self-published
independencies,
the first to preach
firmly the idea
of rebuilding Armenia's
independent statehood
and deny any other solutions
like becoming a member
of the renewed Soviet
Union or Confederation.
The first sum is
that publication
in 1988 was [inaudible].
Bi-monthly which was
published by the Union
of Difference of Armenian Cause.
Several months later UDAC
started the [inaudible]
publication, [foreign words],
Armenian Cause in Russian.
And the same year in May,
the National Self-Determination
Union started its new
publication, [foreign
words], Motherland.
[Foreign words] was a national
political publicist journal
which was repeat
by [foreign words],
one of the founding members
of NSDU and national hero.
In total in sum is that
period in 1988/1991,
11 issues of [Inaudible]
Journal was published.
It covered wide range
of subject areas.
For example, national
materials of the fifth issue
of 1988 are divided in
the following chapters --
call to [inaudible] or All
Armenian National Movement,
opalescence of history,
truth without borders,
thinking loudly,
human rights defender,
and is the [inaudible] documents
and Armenian freedom fight.
Letters were more
[inaudible] were published
in 1994/'98 and 2000.
Although first independent
periodical,
the newspaper [foreign words],
was published on
October 24, 1987.
The evolution of some is that
really began in February,
1988 with the movement
for the reunification
of Nagorno-Karabakh and
Armenia, generally referred
to as the Karabakh Movement.
The most influential
periodical [inaudible]
and [foreign words] published
by the NSDU [inaudible]
of the same [inaudible].
Publications of the
Karabakh Committee
and all Armenian National
Movements including the [foreign
words], Bulletin,
[foreign words], Speaker,
and [foreign words], Et Cetera.
The other and official
self-publication was
Mashtots .
It began to be published
on April 8, 1988,
The editors were
[foreign words].
In fact, [foreign words]
was the literary nickname
of the famous journalist and
publicist, [foreign words].
By the way, [inaudible]
recently --
he's working on different
documentaries and the link
in the bottom you
can find on Twitter.
It's about the Armenian
and Russian [inaudible]
and you can find several
interesting interviews
with those people who published
in Armenian [inaudible]
is that newspapers.
Mashtots have published
20 issues.
It was also of scale
more like brochure,
but the scale was inconsistent.
If the second issue published
in 1989 had 61 pages,
the third could have 38 pages.
The third published
was also typewritten
on a plain A5 format paper.
The pages were bound
and enumerated.
It highlighted those pictures
of Karabakh Committee members,
the historic loopholes of the
First Republic of Armenia,
especially those that during the
Soviets were kept in secrecy.
For instance, in the May,
1989 issue the memoirs
of the Prime Minister of the
First Republic of Armenia,
Hovhannes Kajaznuni,
were published.
These topics were not
only a closed door
for the Soviet press, but also
many of the political figures
of the first republic were
considered anti-Soviet,
and topics about them were
not permitted by the censors.
And that time, I was
a Deputy Director
of the National Library,
and our closed talks
for political reasons, it had
like a 57,000 different items.
Could you imagine how
much was the, you know,
censorship taking
over the library.
In the fifth number of
Mashtots , self-published,
brought it out in
September, 1989.
A well-known historian
and linguist,
Raphael [foreign word], the law
of excluding the third
force article was published.
Later on, it was republished in
[inaudible] Daily and got a lot
of public attention in
Armenia and Diaspora.
Moreover, according to
historian [foreign words],
this was the article
that made Mashtots
Mself-publication prominent.
It wouldn't be an exaggeration
to claim that the article served
as a guideline for the Karabakh
Movement as the author called
on to rely only on own forces.
Why in solving the problems
with neighbors highlighted
the importance
of eliminating the third party,
as the third parties
have their own interests.
It is worth to note that for
the first time in 70 years,
the people living in Soviet
Union were not only listening
about becoming independent
from Russia, but also a call
to solve the problems
on their own.
This was not accepted
without [inaudible] though.
In autumn, 1989, most of
the official newspapers were
under strong influence
of Armenian revolution.
In October/November [foreign
words] and Avant-Garde ,
those are newspapers
published in Armenia,
started publishing
news and articles
to highlight the activities
of the All Armenian
National Movement.
During the [inaudible] a new --
a few newspapers and few issues
of periodicals were still being
printed in the established press
in the traditional number.
The sum is that period of an
official period because ended
with the first issue of the
[inaudible] newspaper published
on November 2, 1989,
on the occasion
of the All Armenian National
Movement First Congress.
Since January, 1990, [Inaudible]
continued its regular
uninterrupted publication
in a last run.
In 1989, there were three
unofficial publications
which were published at
state printing houses.
However, the sum is that period
because did not disappear,
and the competition between all
the new periodicals entered a
new stage.
The years 1990/'91 began a new
phase which we have defined
as the Period of Transition.
We have used the term transition
because the official press
at long last did not withstand
the competition and collapsed,
clearing the road for the
new one's while the --
at the same time, new
global changes had started,
from the past to the present,
from forced
to self-determination,
toward independence.
In 1991, the traditional
political parties,
namely [foreign words] Armenian
Revolutionary Federation --
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
-- Democratic Liberal Party
of Armenia, Social Democrat
and [foreign words], Social
Democrat [inaudible] Party,
were reestablished
and subsequently began
publishing activities
on [inaudible].
On February 16, 1991,
the first issue of --
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
-- was published, although the
[foreign word], the founders,
were five council members -
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
-- and others.
But their fact rate
was the organ
of Democratic Liberal
Party of Armenia.
Within the course of years,
[inaudible] among the pioneers
that brought the cultural
Western journalist practices
in Armenia.
The other influential
publication was [foreign words],
Homeland .
An official of Armenian
Revolutionary Federation
[foreign words].
Central Committee
of [foreign words].
In mid-1993, the [foreign
words] daily reached to 55,000
which was the largest
opposition [foreign words].
The Armenian Revolutionary
Federation established its own
printing house [foreign words],
that was the only
alternative print house
to the [foreign words] owned
[inaudible] publishing house.
Their periodical press
was printed either
by [foreign words] or [foreign
words] printing houses.
And at the end of
1996 the Republic
of [inaudible] the Minister
of Justice have reduced it
already 54 political parties
and sociopolitical organizations
of which almost half have
or had their own
organ print newspaper.
Among the core topics
of discussion,
in sum, is that periodicals.
Those are the Armenian
[inaudible] issue
which direction to follow.
Either keep them ordering if
they're not Armenian or return
to the language roots
and implement the
classical Armenian.
Many [inaudible] is that --
many [inaudible] is that
periodical [foreign words]
as a modern supplements --
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
-- were published solemnly
in classical Armenian.
It was kind of back-to-the-roots
movement
and the language reform was
among the mainstream of changes.
[ Inaudible Speaker ]
-- indicated their titles and
subtitles in classical Armenian.
The issues of unification
of the Armenian language
has been considered as one
of the directions of
greater consolidation
of Eastern and Western Armenia.
In the bottom part,
in the middle,
you can see there is a
announcement in the first issue
of [foreign word]
Periodical that they --
in the future they going
to print their newspaper
in classical Armenian which
never happened, by the way.
In order to stress
their independence,
many periodicals used various
terms to stress their status,
such as independent,
non-governmental, free,
alternative, democratic,
et cetera.
It is difficult to precisely
define some [inaudible]
when it became possible
to reduce all periodicals
without any difficulties.
Some publishers, in order
to show the independence,
refused to reduce
the publications.
In this manner, stressing and
expressing their autonomy.
The majority of these
periodicals were typewritten
and produced by photocopying,
almost always the word
of polygraphical design
and illustrations.
Yet they had a great advantage
over the official periodicals.
They were preaching in the
language of truth and freedom.
As the first tip, many official
periodicals were renamed a good
read of their Communist
stamped names.
Like every Armenian newspaper,
they had that "Workers
of the World Unite."
As a first fine of
change, these, you know,
epigram disappeared
from all the newspapers.
And even -- 1990s a
very interesting year
because in mid-'90,
I believe in May,
the first parliamentary
elections were in Armenia
where the Communist monopoly --
they lose their power
in Armenia,
so many newspapers
starting like the, you know,
changed their appearance
like there was --
every newspaper had a Lenin
medal or something like that.
And they -- first they lose
their medals, the [speaking
in foreign language], but still
-- see, this is a newspaper.
Only one issue was
published in 1990
by [Inaudible] Literary
Journal,
Literary Journal
and Newspaper .
And the first issue
-- still it had --
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
-- like the publishing house
of Central Committee of Party.
I have another journal.
You see it in -- on the top.
Not journal, sorry.
A newspaper.
It is interesting.
It -- this was also published
in '90, but never gone to --
for dissemination because it was
censored by the new, you know,
new government of Armenia.
Still for the political reasons.
Obviously you see [inaudible]
and you see the Turkish-Armenian
side [foreign words].
So all, you know, print
run was kept somewhere.
I don't know.
But I have 10 copies,
so these copies are
for the Library of Congress.
You can keep it.
[ Applause ]
Not only in Armenia, but in,
let's say, in the Diaspora
in Soviet Republics, several
Armenian newspapers in Russian,
in Armenian, appeared
in many countries --
in republics including
Russia, Estonia, in Georgia,
in Ukraine, in Kiev --
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
So these changes were
happening everywhere.
And to summarize
my presentation,
and to [inaudible] is the
differences to emergence
of the contemporary
Armenian press,
I can sum up that
1987/1990, we saw a rise
of those periodicals
approximately
about 15 known traditional
journals
and newspapers appeared.
Their role as [inaudible]
of the establishment
of new Armenian media
can't be over-estimated.
And this is the first issue
of [foreign words] official.
Many independent journalists
and they criticized
at that time our new government
because what does it mean
to have official newspaper?
So you are continuing the same
traditions like in Soviet times.
It was a [inaudible] has done.
Now you have under your
control [inaudible].
What's the difference?
On October 8, 1991, the
Supreme Soviet of Republic
of Armenia passed a law
on periodicals and
other mass media.
Therein emerged the legal
framework of regulations
of the periodical press
and its activities.
Some [inaudible] because
either transfer it
into official publications
or [inaudible] you
to mass media environment
changes.
Time to time, when due to
political tensions and turmoil,
media was on under
government attack.
We witnessed a new kind of
[inaudible] papers and flyers.
For example, during the '94 ban
of Armenian Revolutionary
[inaudible],
party government forced to close
not only [foreign words] weekly,
but also several
literally women's cultural
and youth publications,
and this newspaper
or [inaudible] was
published 99, just 99.
They were indicating 99 copies
and they could publish it,
you know, without
any registration.
This is end of my presentation.
And thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Levon Avdoyan: I must add
that Nerses knows very well
that I love getting donations to
the collection, so [laughter],
if any of you would like to
leave donations on your way out,
we would be glad to accept them.
>> I'll do it.
>> Levon Avdoyan: Yes.
My colleague, Dr. Paul Kergol,
will be glad to take them
from my hands and make sure
that they are catalogued
and made available
to you if I like you.
No [laughter].
Whether I like you or not.
I have the great honor
to actually introduce another
friend and great librarian.
He's presently the President
of the Armenian Library
Association.
He is the Director of the
National Library of Armenia.
And I have to tell,
Tigran, before you go up,
I have to tell a story.
The first time I did this, the
only place I could find a book
that a researcher needed
was in the National Library.
So I wrote to Tigran and
I said, is it possible?
How can you get a copy?
And he says, well,
I'll look into it.
And I think it was two days
later, maybe three days later,
I had in my hands to hand
onto this researcher a complete
digital page-turner copy
of that book.
This is what kind of
a librarian he is.
[ Applause ]
So I am going to introduce
Tigran Zargaryan who will speak
on the Pan-Armenian
Digital Library in Action,
Connecting the Diasporas,
Bridging Knowledge.
.
>> Tigran Zargaryan: Thank you.
And, Levon, I want to
thank you for organizing
such a wonderful event.
Very useful.
One correction.
I have never been the president
of a library association,
never -- so, just
a small correction.
And such is my presentation
will be about the technologies
and how -- this a bookmark.
I will put after my
presentation there.
Some weeks thereafter
you can think, keep them,
and you can use and share
with your colleagues.
So political culture
and economic life
of each nation is connected
with a geographic place
which carries the
name of that nation,
a place that has been
populated by the majority
of the given ethnic group for
centuries, where they lived
and flourished, and transferred
their unicultural [inaudible]
to the next generations.
As for the Armenians,
the situation's a
little bit different.
During its centuries of
destroying despite the fact
that [inaudible] they took,
Armenian nations established
communities, built churches,
opened schools and [inaudible]
colleges all over the world.
They created and passed
on to the next generations
a huge number of treasures
and masterpieces
including manuscripts,
Armenian relevant early
prints which are preserved
in the different libraries
[inaudible] centers, private
and family collections
worldwide.
This resulted in the creation
of a [inaudible] network
under the name spiritual
Armenia,
from a single [inaudible]
Constantinople [inaudible],
from Amsterdam to [inaudible],
from Italy to [inaudible]
and Transylvania.
All the centers for spiritual
Armenia were connected
with each other and
had one common goal --
to protect Armenian language
to reestablish statehood.
The Armenian National Council
declares their independence
with Armenia on 28th
of May, 1918.
One of the first decrees
of the government was
about the National
Library of Armenia
which was established
in June 5, 1919.
Since that time,
the National Library
of Armenia has been collecting
and preserving Armenia
prints published worldwide.
The Armenian collection has
about one and one million items.
Amongst their titles are the
first Armenian printed book,
the Friday Book .
Fifteen prayers [inaudible].
It's the first Armenian
periodical [inaudible] The
Herald , produced
in [inaudible].
The first Armenian
printed bible,
the first Armenian printed map,
and many other unique
publications.
During the past 100
years, the Library,
being the largest repository
of the Armenian language
publications in the world,
has become one of
the central nodes
of the Spiritual
Armenian Network.
And as their major cultural
hub is actively bridging values
for us.
We teach other and
with Motherland.
The Repository of
Ancient Manuscripts --
Matenaduran, Mother See of
Holy Echmiadzin Library,
Mechitarist Congregation
or [inaudible] Library
of the Armenian Patriarchates
of Constantinople,
the Goodman [inaudible] Library
of the Armenian Patriarchate
of Jerusalem, the Library of
the Armenian Catholicosate
of Cilicia, Holy Savior
and Catholic Library
in [inaudible] function
of important centers
of the Spiritual
Armenian Network.
Materials belonging
to the Armenian rich
and heritage are
scattered all over the work
in different cities whereas some
of these places have thriving
Armenian communities in the past
such as [foreign words] in
Transylvania, [foreign words]
in India, [foreign
words] in Russia,
[foreign words] the Ukraine,
and [foreign words] in Crimea.
In these communities there
still are Armenian unique book
collections forgotten and
abandoned, that are awaiting
to be cleaned from the death,
catalogued, and preserved
in normal library conditions.
It is important for
scholars to have access
through their primary sources
which include historical
and legal documents, eyewitness
accounts, statistical data,
pieces of creative writing,
[inaudible] recordings,
speeches, and artifacts.
With all of librarians is
to open such primary sources
to the researchers by preparing
bibliographic bibliographies,
as complete as possible.
Understanding the advantages
of the printed bibliographies,
being aware that
information technologies
and Internet are
acting as key supporters
in the knowledge
bridging process,
having grouped theoretical
basis amongst the libraries
and from the National
Library of Armenia
on developing digital libraries.
A working group often
accepts publishing models
and creative comments
licensing schemas,
and with [inaudible] prepares
library staff to increment,
maintain, induce
[inaudible] products
for building [inaudible]
heritage institutions.
The National Library of
Armenia, in close cooperation
with the fundamental scientific
library of the academia sciences
in [inaudible] projects.
Development of book database,
creation of the human catalog
of Armenian continuing
resources,
coordinating Armenian libraries
[inaudible] activities.
All these are good examples
on connecting the
[inaudible] digital libraries
for building an Armenian
digital library.
So, the first one.
Armenian book database.
Total number of bibliography
records is 127,579.
Why I am just [inaudible]?
Because this is very close
to what Armenians had produced
unique titles from 1512,
I think until 2016/'17.
This number could go up to
1000-30,000, but no match.
So we can state that
Armenians have produced
so much titles during
their printing history.
More than 12,000
digitized books are attached
to the relevant bibliographic
records.
And this number is growing.
Main sources for having
bibliographic records are
[inaudible] and libraries'
collections --
UK, USA, Europe-based libraries
on [inaudible], digitized books
from our products from
[inaudible] to Jerusalem,
New [inaudible] and Istanbul.
Although [inaudible]
digitization activities
for the books are carried out in
the National Library of Armenia
and even from the [inaudible]
scientific libraries,
several international projects
are of [inaudible] for us,
so those are the
Europeana Project
which is covering all Europe and
the special national libraries.
UNESCO is [inaudible] program.
Google Books Project,
the [inaudible] Digital
Library [inaudible] verification
for the research
and the archiving
of Armenian memory [inaudible].
This is from Marseilles, France.
Also some research institutions
and universities in Armenia
which have joined the
Open Access Initiative
and they're mounting
their publications
in the open access domain.
The European and [inaudible]
Digital Library platforms are
very useful.
In both we find early
Armenian printed books
which are not included in
any of the bibliographies.
So thanks to the digital
technologies, we were able
to find in different European
libraries a digital [inaudible]
of 12 foreign language rare
books containing Armenian text
which were not included
in their publication,
The Armenian Book
, in 1512, 1800.
The number of -- and this
covered early prints is
much higher.
Let's say last year our
videographers visited the
Istanbul Municipal Library
and we found there
19 new book titles.
In the Armenian Patriarchate
in Constantinople
in their library we
found 84 new book titles.
So these are titles which
had never been included
in any bibliographies.
So the Union Catalog of
"Armenian Continuing Resources."
Total number of the
bibliographic records is 5808.
This includes newspapers,
journals, yearbooks, bulletins.
More than 3 million
digitized pages are already
fully accessible.
Again, our partners from
[inaudible], Istanbul, Antilles,
are not only participating
in digitization activities,
but are also providing
us with new titles
for [inaudible] you can see.
They are on the screen.
And you just -- Professor
[inaudible].
He mentioned -- he
[inaudible] I think newspaper
around [inaudible].
I check now database and
not any record for this.
So maybe this is --
[ Inaudible Speaker ]
-- material.
In any case, will be interesting
just to discuss with you
because still we find lots of --
a lot interesting titles for us.
So we don't know any
information about that.
The database is a good
of Armenian periodical,
is a good resource
for researchers
and also for statistical data.
It is having very
high hits from U.S.,
a lot of requests are coming.
Such as it is further
down [inaudible] so --
especially [inaudible]
center start using the data
from this database.
So we can see that
5808 titles are divided
by publication type in this way.
So, as you can see the numbers.
Another interesting source --
the last bibliography for
the periodicals was published
in Armenia in 1986
by [inaudible].
It covers the time period 1795,
the first Armenian periodical
was published, until 1980.
So you can see some
of cities, not all.
And in red we indicate total
number of periodicals published
in those cities according
to our database.
So we can see that in
Boston, according to Babloyan,
46 titles; according
to our database, 58.
In New York, according
to Babloyan, 87;
according to our database, 142,
from which four are periodicals
in Turkish with Armenian
letters.
So in USA, seven periodicals
were published in Turkish
with Armenian letters.
Total number according
to Babloyan is 298;
according to our
database, is 464.
So very big difference.
And these numbers
still will be changing
because of the [inaudible]
first in a search
and they are still finding
new titles, new titles.
So cities, you know, US
cities which were not included
in the Babloyan's bibliographies
-- so we can see Paramus,
Morton Grove, Belmont, et
cetera, et cetera, et cetera.
Now Armenian Libraries
Union Catalog.
All solutions are based
on Free/Open Source
Software products.
Actually, Armenian Libraries --
we do not use any commercial
products, from service solutions
to the library systems.
Everything is based
on free/open source.
So products in the systems are
maintained by the librarians,
which is very interesting.
So they are doing the
maintenance of the systems,
of those systems, with more than
one and two million bibliography
and [inaudible] and more
than 5 million items.
This is a unit resource
for researchers, students,
library patrons worldwide.
Public, academic, community,
and university libraries
from Armenia are active
participants of the project.
It's worth mentioning
that the repository
of ancient manuscripts
and Mechitarist Congregation
have also joined this project,
which means that
two important nodes
of spiritual Armenia
will be [inaudible].
We have finished our training
courses with [inaudible],
and now a lady from [inaudible]
by the Mechitarist Congregation
is passing training courses
and after that she
will start to compare
and correct Mechitarist
Congregation card catalog,
now metaphonic form, which will
be a huge help for all of us.
So the weight of the
U.S.-based universities
and Armenian Studies Centers
has a spiritual Armenian note,
and for supplying
the Armenian book
and the Armenian Continuing
Resources Data Business
with information is becoming
more and more important.
The Healthy Choice Digital
Library Initiative wishes
Armenian Collection is a
real help for all of us.
The Library of Congress with its
rich Armenian Collection could
have to ask another
note in the USA.
There are many unexplored
private collections,
a university library collection
which should be examined.
And currently we're considering
establishing professional
relationships with
these organizations.
By the way, we can supply our
viewers' library electronic
[inaudible] with
Armenian script records
with high-quality Armenian
script records in [inaudible],
so if anybody first time that
they hear is interested on that,
we can provide you
freely with those records.
We are confident that much
more unknown titles of books
and [inaudible] because
will be discovered.
Here we see, [inaudible]
possibilities.
We saw a U.S. Diaspora.
So what's next?
Just as I mentioned, we now
are organizing training courses
for the Library [inaudible]
and in Armenia
and from our Diasporas, teaching
them on modern technologies,
on machine [inaudible]
rules, and more.
And programming languages
because now our [inaudible]
are doing --
are developing some small
software pieces for us.
As a result of military
conflicts, immigration,
economic crisis in
our communities,
we already have abandoned
all forgotten libraries.
So if audience of here, you
know also about such libraries,
please keep us informed about
existence of such libraries,
or here in U.S. or in
Europe or in Middle East.
And with the help of Minister of
Diaspora, Minister of Culture,
Minister of Foreign Affairs, we
will try to organize transfer,
transportation of
those collections
to the National Library
of Armenia.
Now we are [inaudible] one
very interesting project
in preparation with the Poznan
Supercomputing Center Institute
for Informatics and Automation
Problems of the Academy
of Sciences of Armenia and the
Fundamental Scientific Library
-- Development of the
Pan-Armenian Digital Library.
The system will enable to
create professional repositories
of digital documents and share
them with interested people
and systems on the Internet.
Data exchange is based
on generally accepted
standards and protocols.
And Pan-Armenian Digital Library
will offer the users many
powerful possibilities such
as searching for content
of the collected resources,
searching bibliography
descriptions using [inaudible]
dictionary, grouping
digital publications
and navigating their structure.
The system will operate on
virtual servers environment.
We have parallel
computing features using the
cloud solutions.
And I hope that you
will come in two years.
We'll be able to develop an
optical recognition engine
for Armenian handwritten
and printed characters using
deep learning approach.
Here we are cooperating with
some of our European partners.
So we are working, because this
is really very, very important,
very, very important
topic for us now.
And I came with my presentation
an African proverb saying that
"if you want to walk
fast, walk alone.
If you want to walk
far, walk together."
So I think that now we have
started to do a step together.
We do have very interesting
findings with the help
of our Diaspora partners,
and I hope that we will
continue our preparation
on behalf of Armenian nation.
So, thank you.
[ Applause ]
So as I mentioned,
here are the bookmarks.
Wait until you can pick them.
And just a small announcement.
So, Levon, can you
join me please?
This is a small surprise.
So, Levon Avdoyan is a great
scholar, researcher, librarian,
geographer, organizer.
So a person with many hats.
So in recognition of his work,
let me to read this just.
"National Library of
Armenia, Hakob Meghapart,
or jubilee [inaudible].
Awarded to Dr. Levon Avdoyan,
Armenian/Georgian [inaudible]
Specialist Near East Section,
African and Middle
Eastern Division
of the Library of Congress.
In recognition of his important
contribution to the development
of modern library system in
Armenia, for [inaudible] input
in the Armenian studies, and
for [inaudible] connections
between American and
Armenian Library [inaudible]."
So, my friend, this is for you.
[ Applause ]
This is it.
I'll give you the medal.
So Hakob Meghapart
first Armenian printer.
>> Levon Avdoyan: Thank you
>> Tigran Zargaryan:
Oh, this is for you.
And this is a [inaudible],
a small token
of Armenian National
Library [inaudible].
>> Levon Avdoyan:
May I say something?
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
Thank you very much.
What Tigran doesn't know
-- I'm greatly honored.
But what Tigran doesn't
know is that as soon
as I retire I am going to spend
several months in Armenia.
And I might -- I'll
probably spend many
of them in this building.
>> Tigran Zargaryan: Is welcome.
You are --
>> Levon Avdoyan:
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
Unexpected.
But thank you.
Wonderful.
Oh, the Hakob Meghapart, in case
you don't know, was the printer
of that first Armenian
book in --
I prefer 1512, but I know
Sylvia [inaudible] 1511.
No truer words have been spoken
than by Tigran, and Nerses,
but the library community is
so interconnected, you know.
Many people -- eyes
glaze over when we talk
about library science,
but it is interconnected,
and we do work together
very well.
We are now on to our last talk,
and we're going back
to the 19th century.
And I did this purposely because
there's a surprise at the end
of this talk that I won't
particularly tell you about.
About 10 years ago we procured a
manuscript by Pietro Bianchini.
I won't say anything
more about him
because our speaker will
certainly fill us in about him.
And there is something special
about seeing something you
have acquired come to life.
And this is what we want to have
happen to all our acquisitions.
So, brilliant musicologist,
composer.
I mean, I would -- whatever
I have done in scholarship
and librarianship I would trade
to be able to be a musician.
People know that about me.
From the Czech Republic, a
great storyteller I have come
to learn, Mr. -- Dr. Haig
Utidjian, who will be speaking
about sublime and
celestial Pietro Bianchini
and an Ode for the Patriarch .
[ Music ]
>> Haig Utidjian: Thank you
very much, indeed, Levon,
for the I would say
excessively kind introduction
which nonetheless I
appreciated very much indeed.
This is not the manuscript
I intend
to talk about, ladies
and gentlemen.
I shall be talking about a
particularly beautiful Armenian
manuscript of an
ode that has been
in use during the Armenian
Devine Liturgy for probably
at least three centuries
"[Inaudible], oh, ye chosen one
of God," which Bianchini
transcribed and harmonized.
Nonetheless, I thought that if
I started with that manuscript
which I will give it the bulk
of the present talk, you would,
of course, with justification,
ask who on Earth Bianchini was,
because he's not as well as
known as he deserves to be,
either in Armenian circles
or in even internationally.
I was extremely fortunate
in being able
to locate a manuscript
of this Sinfonia from
which we just heard a
soundbite recorded specifically
by the [foreign words] Orchestra
in Prague under my direction
with the very kind
permission of the procurators
of the St. Marks
Basilica in Venice
for whose orchestra
the piece was composed
and performed in 1863.
Uniquely, we have permission to
play this excerpt this afternoon
and [inaudible] the time so I do
feel privileged that I was able
to present you this
little fragment.
To give you a little idea
of who Bianchini was.
He was an Italian
Venetian-born musician described
by various Armenians as --
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
He was a child prodigy as
first composer and violinist.
He was prolific as a composer.
He has two masses, two
requiems, a large number
of orchestral pieces,
chamber music,
music for the [inaudible]
instruments,
some [inaudible]
music, but very little
of his artwork has
been published at all.
And, indeed, what he's most
remembered for is the fact
that he published his
own transcriptions
of all the [inaudible]
of the Armenian Divine
Liturgy which he harmonized
on the basis of the chance
he had heard performed
by the Venetian [foreign
word] fathers in San Lazarof.
And that is what he may be
remembered for at the moment,
although he deserves to be
known very much better both
in Armenian circles
and in others.
Now, there is, in fact,
one piece that very
many Armenians know,
but without in fact knowing that
Pietro Bianchini composed it.
And it is actually a piece
that is very, very opposite
to this occasion, given
that I have the privilege
of participating in the
[inaudible] Lecture Series.
It is called [foreign words],
a rousing song, a march,
in which [foreign words]
of the [foreign words]
dynasty is rallying his troops
so that they will take their
vengeance for the [inaudible].
Now, this was a poem
composed by --
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
-- monk, botanist, polymath
poet, Father [foreign language]
who was an almost exact
contemporary of Bianchini's.
And I managed to find a very
interesting historical recording
of this piece made by none other
than the Nightingale of Darron,
as he was known,
[foreign words],
the Armenian tenor [foreign
words] who was a friend
of protege of [foreign words].
And I should like
now, very briefly,
to play you a little
bit of [foreign words].
Many of you will have heard
the melody without knowing
that Bianchini composed it.
[ Music and Singing ]
Time is short, but I did want
you to hear a sufficient beat
of the excerpt so that we could
include the magnificent high
notes with which he ended.
[Foreign words] was a soloist
in La Scale in Milan and in --
at the Paris Opera as well.
And he was singing [foreign
words] with the words
by Father Ghevont Alishan,
and music by none other
than Pietro Bianchini,
the author of the manuscript
I'm going to talk about.
But one last thing
before I start doing so --
just to give you a sort
of feel about the circles
in which Pietro Bianchini
circulated.
I should like to invite
you to consider three
of the delicatees [assumed
spelling] of his various works,
manuscripts, publications.
They are none other than
King Victor Emmanuel II,
the King of Italy, for whom
Bianchini composed an orchestral
piece, [foreign words],
to celebrate the
annexation of Venice in 1866.
But the other two were no
less formidable characters
within the Armenian milieu.
The middle gentleman
was Abbott General
of the [inaudible]
Congregation of Venice,
Archbishop [foreign words].
A formidable personality
himself,
and a towering intellectual
who would deserve a
[inaudible] lecture
in his own right if
it were possible.
And the third is nonother
than the Catholicos
Patriarch Steven Peters,
Step'anos Petros X Azarean,
who was very distinguished,
particularly as an
ecclesiastical leader
and ecclesiastical diplomat.
And he is the delicatee
[assumed spelling]
of the beautiful manuscript
that is held by the Library
of Congress to which I
should now like to turn.
This is what the
dedication page looks like.
It is hand-written
by Bianchini himself,
dedicated to the
patriarch on the occasion
of the latter's nameday
which was St. Stephen's Day,
the 26th of December, 1887.
Bianchini ends the letter
by seeking the patriarch's
blessing, approaching,
figuratively, to kiss his hand,
and declaring himself
a "humble servant."
Pietro Bianchini.
And very importantly
Maestro of the Congregation
of the Mechitarist Fathers
of San Lazzaro in Venice.
Bianchini spent many
years working
in San Lazzaro apparently
directing the choir during the
Divine Liturgy.
So, in addition to serving as
Director of Music in a number
of Italian cities,
particularly Northern Italy,
he performed this very valuable
service to the Armenian Monks.
Now the ode in question, and
[foreign words], chosen of God,
is a composition
not of Bianchini's.
Bianchini merely transcribed
the traditional melody.
But it is a work that
preoccupied Bianchini
for several decades in
the course of his career.
And we have various versions
of it which he worked on.
The earliest that I know
was published as part
of a very slim booklet
that is exceedingly rare.
Not only the Mechitarist
fathers,
not even the Mechitarist
fathers in Venice in San Lazaro
or even the Armenian
National Library are
in possession of a copy.
And you can see -- that is the
extreme left-hand side corner.
It consists of two lines,
the melody sung by a soloist,
and a figured baseline as if it
were a piece of baroque music,
indicating one line and
with little numbers,
the chords that should be played
by the organist or
harmonium player.
The second version of it
that we encounter is part
of the entire complete
Divine Liturgy chance.
These were published
in 1877 in San Lazaro.
And there, we find the entire
ode complete with an organ
or harmonium accompaniment.
But there are also
various manuscripts
that I have succeeded
in locating
in the San Lazaro archives
in which Bianchini
made various copies
or arrangements particularly
of the choral component
of the ode typically with
the verbal underlay written
in Latin script suggesting
that probably Italian
professional singers would sing
during the Divine
Liturgies in San Lazaro,
a fact that I found rather
surprising initially.
And in one case and that's
the undated manuscript
that I'm showing you on the
extreme right-hand side,
he has a string orchestra
accompaniment
to almost the entire
Divine Liturgy and it seems
that he had second thoughts.
You see that he crossed
out the orchestra
from the first four measures,
deciding that it should be sung
by solo female voices alone,
one soprano and one alto,
before the chorus comes
in on the fifth measure
together with the strings.
But this is what the version
in our manuscript looks like.
Again, it is the complete ode
with the first two stanzas
of the ode to be sung by a
soloist accompanied by harmonium
or some other suitable
keyboard instrument.
And the remaining stanzas
are included complete
to be sung by a choir.
And after the music, the words
on their own have also been
beautifully copied out.
The first two stanzas in a
kind of Armenian Gothic script
with the word [inaudible]
patriarch highlighted
by being made larger because
usually the words are [Speaking
in foreign language], chosen
of God, oh happy, holy priest.
But the word priest
has been replaced
by the word patriarch
customizing the ode as it were
for the person, to the
person of the patriarch.
And the choral stanzas are
written in a beautiful hand
in another script which is
characteristic of the period.
But the crucial thing is that
the entire ode has been included
and the music for it as well.
And the verbal text, we can
find in another possession
of the Library of Congress
in the beautiful
Constantinopolitan Breviary
of 1768 where you see
it starts at the bottom
of the left-hand side page,
continuing all the way
along the page opposite.
The verbal text, the poetry
is actually rather beautiful.
It makes allusions to the
Book of Exodus from the Bible,
the 28th chapter where
there is a description
of Moses preparing meticulously
and beautifully woven garments,
priestly garments for Aaron.
And the poet, whoever it was who
composed the words of this ode,
likens the celebrant about
to serve the Divine Liturgy
to the person of Aaron.
And in the words of
the poem, it is Christ
who today makes our celebrant
appear under the same form
as Aaron and seeks the
intercession of the priest.
Now, this is full of
polyvalent symbolism
because if we consider the
liturgical use of the ode,
we find that in fact, the ode is
to be sung during the
particularly poignant moment
in the beginning of
the Divine Liturgy.
During those moments when the
celebrant, being the bishop
or of higher rank, is
to fall on his knees
and with overflowing tears --
these are not my words but those
of the rubric, the instructions
in the missal and I'm quoting
from another beautiful
Library of Congress manuscript,
a missal from the year
1722 where you can see
on the left-hand
side the situation.
The celebrant is kneeling.
The proto deacon, the chief
deacon has taken his miter away
and the celebrant is to recite
the very beautiful prayer
by Saint Gregory of
Narek in two parts,
addressed to the Holy
Spirit which he has
to do quietly and
inexpressively.
The Armenian word is [Speaking
in foreign language]
corresponding
to the Greek [Speaking in
foreign language] which in turn,
harks back to the Book
of Romans, chapter eight
where Saint Paul refers to our
own inability to pray properly
but that fortunately, the
Holy Spirit utters these
inexpressible groans by way
of interceding on
our behalf to God.
So you can see there are all
sorts of layers of associations.
The celebrant kneels.
He recites quietly this
prayer during which time,
someone has to sing this ode.
And if you were in the
position of singing the ode,
as I have been, you can never
predict how long this is going
to take.
How many stanzas of the ode you
will require because the rubric
in the middle of the prayer
to the Holy Spirit says
that the celebrant has to repeat
the first part of the prayer
as many times as it takes
until such time as confidence
in the upward contemplation
of light be wonderfully
revealed to the celebrant.
As you might imagine,
one cannot predict
in advance how long it will
take for such confidence
in the upward contemplation
of light and the revelation
of this light will take.
And so, Bianchini was very wise
in providing the entire text
with music just in case.
It is a very beautiful
moment, the celebrant
and the singer both kneel
and usually these days,
unlike this image where the
celebrant is holding the missal
himself from which
to read the prayer.
Two deacons also kneel holding
the missal on either side.
This is another illustration
from Matenadaran missal
of about the same period.
You can see the deacons behind.
One is holding the miter and
the celebrant is kneeling
and saying the prayer.
Rather more recently than the
18th Century, last October,
I had the enormous pleasure
of bringing this melody back
to life by singing this
Bianchini version of the ode
in the Church of the Holy
Sepulchre in Jerusalem.
I was not, of course, singing
from the beautiful Library
of Congress manuscript
itself but rather
from an electronic scan
of it very kindly made
available to me by Levon.
Now, you might like to
ask how old this ode is.
Since when did it
come into existence?
It is a question that I
have not been able to answer
with certainty but I
have tried my best.
We have the very great benefit
that there is a fine catalog
by the later Father [Inaudible],
the former abbot of San Lazaro,
where you can look up
all the odes that are
in all the manuscripts
in San Lazaro,
looking up their first lines.
And there are over
60 manuscripts
that could include this ode
which include odes and litanies.
And only a single one out of
those 66 manuscripts, I think,
if I'm right, includes the ode.
And it is a rather
recent manuscript
as Armenian manuscripts go,
being copied out
in the year 1663.
As it happens, in the Armenian
Church of the Holy Cross
in Venice, a stone's throw
from Saint Mark's
Basilica, as it happens.
Moreover, we read that the
manuscript was discovered
in the 19th Century
by none other
than the poet monk Father Lewond
Alisan whose [Inaudible] we
heard a moment ago
to Bianchini's music.
This is what the
manuscript looks like.
But alas, although other items
in the manuscript have
musical signs on them,
this particular ode, the
ode that interests us,
does not bear musical signs.
But if we look at the
[Inaudible] Monastery in Vienna,
there is a manuscript
from about the same period
but it cannot be clearly dated
as it does not have
a [inaudible]
which does bear musical
signs known as neumes.
Now, that does not necessarily
help us quite as much
as one might hope because
we are sadly unable
to decipher the medieval neumes.
But we can tell various
things by looking
at the notation over the words.
We can see that the
melody, whatever it was,
must have been fairly
simple because the density
of the neumes is not
particularly high.
And we mostly see
rather simple signs.
But we can do a bit
better than that.
We are extremely fortunate
in that a very great genius
and probably the greatest
Armenian musicologist
of modern times,
the Constantinopolitan
Church musician Elia Tntesean
who belonged more or less to the
same generation as Bianchini,
carried out a lot of astute
and meticulous detective
work enabling him not perhaps
to decipher the meaning
of the neumes
but to develop a conjecture,
quite a convincing conjecture
although it is not quite 100%
water tight, according
to which we can tell
with reasonable certainty
the metrical durations
of particular syllables
bearing some neumes
or bearing no neumes at all.
And if we apply his conjecture
to this manuscript of this ode,
we find that there is, indeed, a
very exciting rhythm as follows.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
It continues like this but
then in the middle of the ode,
things get more exciting and the
rhythm changes and it becomes --
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
And then it returns
to the regular five-four
sort of rhythm.
There is a sort of dance-like
lilt to it, isn't there?
And I think that this is,
indeed, the sort of meter
that would have -- that the
ode would have been sung to.
Now, none of the melodies that
are available to us at present
from various traditions
correspond to the neumes
because they are far more slower
and ornate melodies with a lot
of notes being sung
to a single syllable.
But it is interesting to go back
and see what perhaps
this ode may have sounded
like although alas, we are not
able to reconstruct the melody,
only the meter and the rhythm
which we are able to do,
thanks to the pioneering
work of Elia Tntesean.
Now, let us turn to the melody
that Bianchini was
able to transcribe.
Before I do so, however, I
should like briefly to refer
to a little pink slip of paper
that I found bound in the one
of the Bianchini
manuscripts found
in the archives of San Lazaro.
On this occasion, as
on other occasions,
Bianchini was painstakingly
leaving instructions
to his singers, probably
Italian singers,
as to how Armenian sacred
music ought to be performed.
And his instructions
and by saying
that if these chants are
performed as they should,
then the result renders
them sublime and celestial
and that one and the
same time, most pleasing
to our hearts and to our ears.
It is daunting having
sighted these words
to make a feeble attempt to
sing a bit of the melody to you.
It is not my singing that
will be sublime and celestial
but I do hope that my singing
notwithstanding the melody may
perhaps correspond to
such a description.
There would be only
a little sound bite
so that we do not miss the
reception this evening.
[ Music ]
And it continues in this vein.
Time is --
[ Applause ]
I thank you for the
applause which naturally,
I take as being directed
to three people,
Bianchini who transcribed it,
whoever composed the melody,
and of course, the poet
who composed the words.
But it is a privilege to serve
as their advocate in
my very small way.
Now, a question rose in my mind
as I was preparing this lecture.
It was very clear to me from
all the materials that I saw
and from the meticulous
and painstaking nature
of the transcription of
this beautiful manuscript
and the general care that had
been taken in its production
on the part of Bianchini
and it is abundantly obvious
that this man was enamored
of Armenian sacred music
into which he had immersed
himself in a very, very big way.
And although he had
a very active
and distinguished career writing
a lot of pieces in the tradition
of his day -- non-Armenian
pieces, of course --
I wondered if there
could be some means
of finding any possible
connections might he have been
somehow influenced by his
immersion into the sound world
of these ancient Armenian
chants and their modality
in his compositions
in a western style.
Alas, most of his pieces are
unpublished and one needs
to travel to all sorts
of places in Italy
and gradually uncover them,
something that God willing,
I should very much like
to do in future years.
But upon conducting the
Bianchini Symphonia of 1863
and remember, it
was composed a year
after Bianchini published this
ode in a little booklet in 1862,
only a year previously.
After having conducted the
piece, I looked at the score
and then I was struck
by what one might refer
to as a little oddity.
The melody that I
sang of the ode,
it has a very characteristic
motif.
[ Music ]
And this occurs twice
in the first stanza
and another two occasions
in the second stanza.
And it tends to linger in
the mind, at least it stayed
in my mind when I first
looked at the ode.
[ Music ]
And yet, you will recall that
the symphony that we heard,
the Symphonia with which
we started has the theme --
[ Music ]
Now, if we forget about
the rhythm and just look
at the notes and the skeleton --
[ Music ]
-- it is almost identical to
that of the motif in the ode.
This is pure speculation on
my part, ladies and gentlemen.
It might be just the
fancy but I like to think
that subconsciously possibly,
this motif from [Inaudible]
may have lingered
in Bianchini's mind
and somehow re-emerged
as the theme of this Symphonia.
I don't know if this
is indeed the case.
We're not in a position
to ask the master
but it's an intriguing
thought nonetheless.
I should like to end by
saying that this was an age
of cultural titans, people like
Lewond Alisan, [Inaudible],
many others, Elia Tntesean
-- Bianchini himself,
I would also put
in that category.
And it was an exciting era not
only because of an awakening
on the part of the Armenians
but because of the very,
very beautiful fruits
that emerged as the result
of the interaction between
Armenian and European cultures.
And this happened
not only in music.
It happened in terms of
spirituality and theology.
It happened in literature
particularly
in poetry as we all know.
And this manuscript
documents precisely that.
It exemplifies and embodies
one of those fruits,
a Venetian Italian
music transcribing
into western notation
and harmonizing an
ancient Armenian ode.
Had he not transcribed it, we
would probably have lost it
because this melody is not known
to the San Lazaro
monks at present.
And this manuscript is like
a diamond that sheds light
in all sorts of direction
suggesting avenues
for future research.
And I feel so very
fortunate and blessed
that this manuscript has
been preserved and these kept
at the Library of Congress
for our own generation
and future generations
to study and to enjoy.
And moreover, it is here
where it is really disseminated
electronically to anyone
who may care to have a look at
it which is something that is
of very great value and which
the Library of Congress shares
with the National
Library of Armenia.
And I feel above all, a
tremendous and profound debt
of gratitude to Dr.
Levon Avdoyan,
thanks to whose excellent
nose for such things
and unerring instinct
and his untiring efforts,
this manuscript has
been acquired
by the Library of Congress.
So please accept my
gratitude for this as well
as many other things of which
today's unique conference is
but one.
In thanking Levon, I should
also like to thank a number
of other individuals
and these institutions
without whose generosity
and kindness,
this research would
not have been possible.
Thank you very much indeed
for your attention,
ladies and gentlemen.
[ Applause ]
>> Levon Avdoyan: Alas, this day
has actually flown by for me.
It's been a combination of
several months of planning.
I would truly want to thank all
of my speakers, our speakers,
some of whom have come
from long distances abroad
and are going to leave sadly.
It is -- people who know me,
I usually just say thank
you if I'm not pleased.
What I am going to say is
true in every single case
which is each and every one
of these papers has
exceeded my expectations
of what I hoped would happen.
And I hope those of you who have
lasted all day, will go away
with what I wanted you to feel
which is Armenian
history is extremely more
than just a few isolated facts.
So thank you for attending.
Thank you for my
wonderful speakers.
And I hope you will all attend
the Smithsonian Folk Life
Festival in the next two weeks
and enjoy Armenian culture
on a different plane.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.